all right
and we are live the last word water free
edition
with evantas and thai guy travis
fresh off of a missed friday but we're
back the technical gods have blessed us
first let us talk to the cheetah the man
of the hour the man that has survived
the most catastrophic failure known to
man but is still with us how are we
doing
sir
i'm here i have no idea honestly how i'm
here because if you guys knew how what
so a lot of people have seen on twitter
some people were on the show a lot of
people who are close enough to me know
generally what happened but
i've got these like basically you know
type like stainless steel water
re-enactment be careful yeah i know i
know everybody's all touchy they're so
far separate right now it's not an issue
good but it holds about like 20 25
ounces of water
and like the top is basically the
biggest part of it and that's what
actually was not on the top of it
because i was like making a mix of my
advanced qg in the morning and had
everything in there and the top was not
on so there was no like limitation no
like slight slow flow just like the
whole it was like a bucket of water was
poured on top of my pc when i spilled it
literally an open bucket just whoosh and
the problem is i recently got a case to
try and help with like airflow
and it's like the corsair 5000d
great case by the way um not it's not
sponsored anything but i actually really
like the case for airflow but
unfortunately it's open in the top so
it's not like you poured on the top and
it kind of ran down the sides and you
got to clean it off
it ran through the fans through the
radiator down onto like the motherboard
dripping through the pc pha through the
gpu like it was
everywhere and i was just like there was
a point where i thought my monitor like
kind of flickered off was like oh god
there goes the gpu and i basically
pulled the power cable out of the back
as quick as i kind of realized i could
that was my first reach to try and cut
the power there's still some residual
power at that point but
basically at that point like these guys
were on the discord call with me because
i jumped back in with the phone
i'm over here like ripping parts out of
the computer dismantling it as fast as i
can i literally have like isopropyl
alcohol
when i got that thing over like when i
got my motherboard out i'm literally
like the whole bottle of i suppose i'm
spraying my motherboard with isopropyl
alcohol at this point because i feel
like i can't hurt it
it was so destroyed so it was like that
a hair dryer a whole lot of q-tips a
toothbrush
i went through everything
surgery you put it in the er immediately
well i dismantled i have a founder's
edition 3090 and i've dismantled it and
actually put like better thermal pads on
for the memory which has actually helped
a lot so i've taken it apart before so
it's like okay
i didn't care at this point like i took
the heatsinks off the motherboard i
dismantled everything
and somehow first thing the test was
like the gpu because i actually recently
won a new egg shuffle and helped
somebody else get a graphics card and i
was like i know there's a graphics card
like in shipment right now
maybe i can talk to that content creator
and see about getting it if mine died so
my first priority was my gpu
to try and test it and i have a computer
upstairs where
um we have beat saber set up it's a
little older computer yep so i have that
set up upstairs and mean that's the one
i played on that's the one i played or
you probably played no you played
downstairs someone brought it downstairs
when i came okay it was it was on
yeah it was on my good computer at that
point it was just that it still works i
moved the gpu up there
um
so i tested it up there for a little bit
i was like hey you know told my wife
it's like hey jump into beat saber we'll
see if like the gpu put a little stress
through it and it actually played well
for a little while
and then it went to a green screen
and i was like oh god oh so you like
it's done done it's done
yeah i thought it was done and
but basically what it was there was
enough power for the gpu
right because the power supply up there
was like 750. this one's like a thousand
so it was just like it ran for a little
while would always sit in windows but
then it just wasn't enough for the
because at that point you attributed
it's a possibility that it was damaged
not realizing it could not be having
enough power pretty much and then my
brother went through the same thing
because he got like a 3080 and he had an
older computer or smaller jeep power
supply when he got his 3080 and his was
like ran for a bit and would turn off so
he had something similar so i was like
kind of going back and forth i gave the
content creator that i'd helped get a
gpu like emotional rollercoaster hell
because i was like i may need that one i
don't maybe i do still so i was just
messing with her even more
um but all somehow between the cleaning
the dismantling lots of tooth brushing
and alcohol q-tips and everything else
and i think i've got like i've
re-thermal pasted everything recently so
it's all fresh
and clean and somehow working at this
point um
no friday was friday morning and it was
cognito and travis saw me on the call
and tom was nice to stand up for a
little bit but he had to run but
like all of them saw my face and later i
talked to cognito and he was just like
dude i
like yeah i basically just thought it i
died so yeah your life flashed before
your eyes the
the i.t gods have blessed you you have a
second leaf so life said we're happy to
have you back in the world of living
computers you gave us a scare being
travis stayed on the call we were just
like man i hope that didn't come back
you know what i'm saying like we would
we would just like pray for the worse
anybody knew how much water actually
went in there
you would never have get i mean i'm
sitting there pulling the gp out of the
socket there's fluid dripping through
this juicy pci socket like
nothing should work right now and
somehow it does so it's like
these parts are apparently a little
beastly because they all survived so no
doubt should i have anything to compete
with this for you hey hold on man i hope
it's before we get into our esteemed
guest
i mean am i allowed to heckle him how
much time do we have
we got to be respectful we're a little
little okay i will say i'm i'm amazed at
his ability to turn that uh technical
catastrophe into another ad for advanced
gg yes yes salute to that yeah i think
that's really important he should shut
out the alcohol company too some joke
about the last word campfire almost
being extinguished
um
maybe we should rename this the splash
zone cog you and i are sitting on the
splash zone of the podcast
like we joked about that and i basically
even i mean my chat when i was actually
able to stream for a little bit
besides the fact that my ac went out the
same day that happened by the way jesus
my ac was out for like the entire
weekend after that that finally got
fixed on monday they make you sweaty
literally i've had no problem with that
but yeah that's been quite a thing what
have you been up to cog
since i was the one with all the
entertainment
i've been good brother just busy you
know obviously defining duke and
lordsgamer.net and iop and all that good
stuff just you know making the rounds
doing stuff i will plug something as we
as we start um if you guys can if you
see pinned on my twitter account at law
cognito please uh one of our destiny
brothers man he is going to go through a
rough year and i have to shout him out
you've heard me probably mention the
name sinister often on this podcast he's
always if you've played destiny with me
or anybody in ilp clan he's always
either raided with you i helped you get
something done so yeah sadly he lost his
mom uh yesterday and uh this year it's
been a rough year he also lost his dad
and grandma to covet 19 complications so
um we're trying to do something special
for him if you get a chance and if you
get out of the kindness and generosity
of your heart you want to help our
brother we're trying to raise something
to kind of funeral arrangements and send
off the family right so salute to
sinister i love you bro he listens all
the time
big fan and uh we know you're going
through it you know you're hurting but
we're going to try to rally for you so
that responsibility is not all on you so
lord sinister my guy sorry to make it
somber sorry no no way to bring it back
to reality after my idiocy so thank you
no doubt no doubt that being said we
have a guest to bring into the show and
he's been patient enough to wait through
my story
um
so
let's do this
[Laughter]
on the pre-show and i just said put it
in rice
that bad so
all right let's do this intro how we do
this
welcome to the last word episode 168
we got a break from trials of osiris as
lord saladin who is long overdue for an
update by the way
grace the tower for another week of iron
banner bounties the helm has kept things
spicy as we got to see the dreaded
conversation between a bird and a
crystal take place
firsthand and we got our final chat with
a god as well
with increased difficulty on the horizon
and a first series of trials experiments
in the rear view we are lucky enough to
be joined by an extremely distinguished
guest around the campfire today to
discuss this crossroads in season of the
lost our guest today has always had a
talent for using his words and there is
a lawsuit from his teen years to prove
it as with many forms of technology he
always has been ahead of his time his
passion for tech made his initial career
choice a likely one that wasn't enough
though working double time to stay ahead
of the curve he built his own community
focused around all things microsoft and
it rocketed into the stratosphere the
watchful eyes of the internet noticed
his talents and the verge was the winner
of this man's silver pin from goldeneye
as a young lad to windows i.t as an
adult you could say he was destined to
end up where he is now
with a new with his new puppy frank by
his side and getting his lunch delivered
from mars his home in the united kingdom
seems to fit him rather well and while a
new while new technology is never too
far away neither his cam neither is his
camera phone go check out this world's
this man's world travelers instagram
seriously jealous
he may not technically hold the title of
lord or earl but anyone who knows his
career wouldn't argue that he deserves
something like that because in the world
of technology and gaming journalism our
guest today is part of wordsmith royalty
we will check with lord cognito after
the show to see if we could work on at
least an honorary elevation to duke so
let's welcome to the campfire the
founder of wind rumors and now senior
editor at the verge with over 5 000
articles and counting a man who has
appeared on nearly every major global
news network the one the only tom warren
sir how are you doing oh
wow one intro
i feel way more important than i think i
am
but yeah hello uh
yeah so i've been a destiny fan and
i've played destiny since the alpha so i
uh i've played way too i think i have
five thousand hours of destiny too
which is
just kind of yeah so yeah i'm a huge
destiny players bro those are rookie
numbers
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't talk about destiny enough like i
tweet about it sometimes and you know
but like is this your first destiny show
have you been on other shows yeah i
don't know i haven't no i just wear an
extension
exclusive exclusive sometimes jumping
people's like twitch streams and say
hello and oh that is nice question stuff
but yeah i haven't actually been on
people's
some of us have made a whole career out
of it
just destiny
what do you do just one game
it's such a complex game though isn't it
so it is it is it's very quite like it's
nothing like it you know before i know
we're gonna get into it but i definitely
you'd have to e-set you up with an
amazing intro i definitely wanted to get
into you know gaming history you know
and you got some really really stand out
titles i saw that golden eye and stuff
like that so like early beginnings as
far as console gaming you know what were
some of the inspirations that kind of
just got you in the game in general
yeah so i had originally i had like a
ps2 um
back in the day and then there was like
this little local uh store near me that
that kind of like imported like consoles
and stuff you know when like stuff back
then like i'm like 37 uh i feel old
but back then that's not the stuff
you had to like get the specific disc or
if you had like a japanese console you
had some japanese games and like oh yeah
all that sort of stuff um and i just
remember taking like i don't know how
many games i had like 20 or 30 ps2 games
and then trading that in for an n64 and
coming home like
we've just wore like one game you know
just the end 64 and golden eye and my
mum being like
what the hell have you done like why
um and i think that was like that was
probably the start of me like being into
games and stuff um
so i obviously i love the n64 apart from
this kind of wacky controller yeah
with the batarang with the analog in the
center yes yes
nothing ever made quite like that is
that yeah made for a three-handed person
as far as i could
i played like gold and i emulated on the
pc like a couple of months ago and uh
he's so weird like playing that again no
you haven't touched if he is it is aged
remarkably poorly i must say
it's impressive i'm sure about it sadly
i'm sure the graphics that are in my
head are still better
by a huge margin than what it actually
is because i mean you go back and you
think like odd job and the shots that
you do you're like i'm picturing golden
of the movie in n64 i'm like
it's kind of trash but in the moment it
was good you know what it did it wasn't
even it wasn't even the graphics for me
it's the i i completely forgot that in
goldeneye you use one analog stick to
control movement and aiming and that is
not good it is that's just rough
resident evil 4 had the same problem but
it got remastered and they added like a
second stick control but
damn man it's rough yeah it's rough
so
i was i was so into like golden eye yeah
i was gonna
remember like speed running all of the
stuff and even like i went to like a
local like uh mall that we had and they
had like this little competition about
like if you could speed run it
over like they had like a month-long
thing so if you were the top speed you'd
win like a golden n64 so i i won that
and it gave it to myself
64.
yeah so okay so that was that's cool
have it you must still have no i don't
know
no
i
i
i haven't kept like a bunch of my old
stuff like i don't have much money
either you kind of like clear stuff out
yeah yeah i'm not nostalgic at all as
soon as the old generation's gone i'm
like well time to get rid of this yeah
we're so bad for like keeping keeping
old stuff like i like to just
and i trash him like i have one thing i
still wish i had and that's my chrono
trigger cartridge everything else i'm
probably okay with but that one is like
that's my game but yeah i was like i've
always done yeah trade it in typically
even though you get like cents on the
dollar but i've always just like ps4 yep
for the pro okay pro for the five yep
just
you know and they make the deals like
occasionally game stops like working
give you 200 i'm like
what
sure like have it take it i don't care
you you can go rip somebody else off for
it i'll take 200 because i got my use
out of it so
i do have the the the
the hard drive that they had you take
out of your n64 with that little plastic
tool when you're doing the expansion
old heart of my n64 it's like one of the
only relics that happens
[Music]
[Laughter]
but for my birthday a few years ago my
girlfriend like booked there's there's a
place near by us in peckham um i think
it's called four quarters or something
like that it's like some really retro
thing she like booked like this whole
area where they had like all old n64s
and like
every generation of console and that was
that was that's a nice lady that's nice
yeah you got a keeper
that's pretty awesome that's what's up i
just want to ask quick before we
transition off goldeneye
you know i i have some family in in in
london and i'm traveling there and
that's how i actually as a young age got
introduced to like the impact of like
james bond so was
goldeneye in the uk like was it like
this massive thing because of also the
popularity of the series and in general
yeah yeah maybe like
i think it was just it was like the
first of its kind really wasn't it of
his
genre really so like i think it was that
and it was like the four player you know
like i remember just taking my n64 to
friends houses and just doing that split
screen multiplayer stuff and yes
like it was it was just so unique um so
i think this was definitely a part of
the bond stuff but okay yeah i was like
the only good shooter until combat
evolved like figured out how to do
competitive shooters like that yeah
and then and then after combat evolve
came out everybody was like oh yeah like
why aren't shooters just on every like
yeah it's perfect for a controller why
isn't there there constantly like that
yeah that sort of experience like kind
of really kind of got me into i think
the n64 was like really like the ps2 was
like great and i loved all the games
there but the n64 was like kind of the
ah you know like that was the
thing for me and then um
then we're not like i really got into
like pcs when i was
after that um and started
like i did some stupid stuff as a
teenager like i'd i'd nick my mom's
credit card and
and
try pc parts and [ __ ]
shout out to thomas
did she like make you return did you
like receive this package and the credit
card bill just kind of went through
she let me keep them and like i think
she i think my parents like basically
fostered my like obsession with pcs
sounds like they were like so i was kind
of lucky he didn't buy
that's for sure
really oh i got the i got to get to the
warren household this is
oh for sure this is amazing
along the road
so it got really into pcs and like
building pcs and i don't know like i
remember we had like a shed in our
garden i don't think what that converts
to in yeah now that we get it yeah sure
yeah yeah um
and and it was like it was just full of
pc parts and just old pcs and [ __ ] like
we used to build pcs for like my sister
my mom and i had like i had the whole
thing like a server active directory
network the whole lot going on it was
just it was just stupid really but
um but that got me into pc gaming
obviously um and steam and everything
else um and particularly returned to
castle wolfenstein so like i was
that was my big one so i was in like
clans we competed in like they had like
an intel gaming tournament in london in
the science museum many years ago it was
like
the very start of like that sort of
thing um i used to go up to like lan
events in manchester and stuff and just
drag my pc oh man those pc's and the
monitor that's like the weight of my
entire body as a child like clts
oh my god crts i got this like 19-inch
dell crt it was like source like this
deep
and just you carry that thing around
doesn't even fit on the little cart you
put it on the card table that's at your
friend's lan house and the cartoon goes
i remember doing like house parties at
like when i was like 16 17.
and i'd take my pc to the party which
sounds really like that sounds like the
most nerdiest thing right now but it was
like full of like mp3s
parties was like so much work it was
like everybody's tv was huge even if
you're doing like a halo land party
which is what i did
the tv was like the biggest thing now
that's like the easiest thing monitor
all right easy
so true so true
return to castle wolfenstein really
kick like that kick that and golden i
really kicked off my love for like first
person shooters basically that's that's
mostly all i play really nicely
well i dedicate most of my time to that
so
so i wanted to touch on this like
journey through journalism you started a
blog when you were
probably before you were driving and
went through like a lawsuit like i got
to know the details on this thing that
happened before you even hit like
adulthood yeah you've gone through a
lawsuit and a blog and it was like yeah
let what what was that whole story how
did that go
yeah so i wrote about this um so the
blog was times new roman like the font
and so i registered that domain name the
uk version
and um
i had it for years and i used to just do
these stupid blogs saying like how i
used to like get drunk at 16 with my
mates and like
i wanted to be famous on the internet i
mean
like if you read it now it's just such
cringes
and all that sort of stuff anyway like
one day i was like you know what times
new roman.com i think the people that
own that should be directing traffic to
me so i was like i pen i pinned off like
a quick email to like whoever i can't
remember the font company that actually
owns times new roman
but i actually dared
to actually email them and be like yo
i've got the uk domain and like you
should would you mind adding a backlink
sort of thing
obviously
that alerted them to the fact that some
16 year old idiot in the uk had uh
registered their domain name and uh so
then i got like this legal letter saying
like like we're not going to sue you but
like we'll give you like 500 pounds for
this tomorrow it's around about that
amount of money for this domain name and
you know like no questions are sort of
things
i was well one part i was like but my
domain and also i was like 500 pound you
know that's gonna that's a new graphics
card and a new processor
yeah um so i was like sure
respectfully i like this hustle your
hustle game is serious though i like
this
you were 16 so the internet was still
the wild west back then wasn't it what
year yeah yeah i remember if yeah when
would that have been
like was this hosted on geocities or
myspace
yeah
it would have been 2 000 right yeah yeah
yeah so that was back yeah
it was dial-up and all that sort of
stuff yeah
that was back when like teenagers were
buying like domain names for like
politicians campaigns and then yeah yeah
yeah for a couple thousand like that was
like crazy you can't you can't do that
anymore like that's no but that was back
when that was back when he was so
competitive as well like i remember
there would be like aols obviously and
free
and all this stuff oh yeah oh yeah and
there was like these rogue ones which
are like for for us like a free dial
like toll free number is oh 800. so they
used to be these ones and they'd like
you can sign on from like 6 p.m for free
all weekend so i would be like clicking
and my modem is like trying it 50 000
times it's just not
session has ended
yes
i love it continue yeah so yeah like
that was that was my domain name gone
wow
i just love that it's named after the
fought times
amazing it's like yeah what was the
motivation for that
i don't know why i think it's just it
was the default font in office at the
time so i was just like yep let's just
go with that but like my nickname at the
time was called tom123 so obviously was
a
a very uninspired uncreative teenager
cool tom one two three ah the
originality
love it love it oh don't try if you got
any questions for tom
uh i guess since now we know how you got
into um
shooters what what got you into destiny
how long have you been playing it and
sort of what's been your relationship
with it yeah so i got into i played the
bait or destiny because a friend was
playing it um and i you know
i thought it was cool and it was like
interesting
there was obviously the grind the loot
and the loot case
yeah that all that stuff was there um
but i think what really got me into it
and this is kind of funny is like i i
think i signed into my xbox on a
saturday my friend was in a party and i
joined it
and um and he was like doing a raid and
i was like what is he doing like what's
going on and they were like you know
fully intense and i was like yo what's
up guys
in the middle i can't remember what raid
it was it would have been one of the
first destiny raids but um
this is in the game all the raids and
stuff and i was like ah this is this is
cool okay i want to i want to play this
so that kind of got me in and then that
got you hooked and
running around collecting spin metal and
stuff you know that kind of got
until somebody reminds me yeah
luke cave is gonna be making an encore
appearance here in
a couple months apparently
i still have friends who when i tell
them i play destiny they're like oh you
run around social spaces collecting spin
metal and i'm like guys it's not like
that anymore okay it's way more annoying
[Laughter]
those different elements of like the
game definitely like i think i always
just saw the potential for the game
which i think has really been fulfilled
like
i know bungie says like it's an mmo but
finally i think we've all seen the
potential for the entire life of the
game like as soon as we get a tease of
something there's always like more
potential that could be there like one
of mine was always like oh we got to see
set bonuses in drifter still waiting on
that to actually pan out like anything
like that for example but yeah potential
i feel like as a word we hear from a lot
of people about the game because
i think the passion is always so deep in
a lot of people because
what everybody hopes could be there
someday and it's always like kind of
flirting with it ish like it's never
never quite there never fully mmo never
full rpg
yeah it's so easy it's a hybrid like mix
isn't it yes but it's it's a mix that no
one's been like obviously anthem tried
division
no one's really been been able to
compete with it have they really like i
also don't want it to be a full mmo i
i'm kind of glad that they're not going
fully there but i i agree there's like
this weird sub genre that mixes a lot of
other things and they've not been able
to replicate it there's been so many
destiny killers
and all of them they're just corpses
like just great tombstones
i just remember the beginning of destiny
when it first came out there was like so
many there's so much uk media's coverage
of it
it was like stealing boyfriends and
husbands away from their families and
stuff
because there was like millions of
people playing at that point
yeah i was working in the ign office
when destiny launched and i remember we
kept posting news about it every day and
there were some people on the team that
were like why
are we doing this like why are there so
many destiny articles and we were like
dude have you seen the numbers
people care about this game like we'll
post like the dumbest article ever it'll
be like here's how to do one tiny thing
inside of destiny and get like a million
views i'd be like yeah like that's nuts
like yeah you can't post
a podcast just for this isn't where is
there still like a top google it wasn't
until a few years ago like the top i
forgot it was in the game
videos of them every week i mean i do
that there's um even the people who run
where's their the website they'll do
their kind of friday streams and like
you know you see people like pretty
good-sized content creators like glad if
he's doing something random have a
couple thousand when they go on for that
little like you know kind of two hour
lead up window and after there's like
three thousand people watching them for
like an hour and it's like this little
pink and it's like i mean there's
content creators like me watching it but
it's like everybody tends to know about
that one thing it used to matter more
but yeah
yeah yeah i think it's it's interesting
now because they've obviously given them
random roles so it's actually
made them
but they need to like i think was it
lucky tempe or someone tweeted yeah that
needs to be randomly dropped throughout
the world
like the hunt for him for him yeah that
would be fun yeah
no doubt
that'd be really annoying he used to be
super important or i remember like he
some weeks he was like the only reason i
logged on i would just log in on friday
go to zurich see if he had anything nope
okay log off nothing new in destiny this
week did you buy cattle horn from him
i did the second week i'm like the only
guy who did i bought it because i
thought it looked pretty and everyone
was like travis you are wasting your
money i was like look how pretty it is
and then afterward everybody was just
like oh god damn like jesus has this gun
and i was just like what up
back then you had to basically try and
get free gallahorn as well because they
were like dim
didn't really exist then so you couldn't
really transfer it easily so yeah that
was the thing man the nightfalls and
just seeing the the reactions of people
who finally get that drop and
the the classism with gallo it was kind
of hilarious
like the worst just because like i had a
buddy who played with a ton
and he was trying to see how many
galleys he could get before i got my
first
he almost had his heavy slot full he
almost had nine before i got my first
one i think he was like seven or eight
so he had to eventually complete it all
but yeah he had a point where he showed
me a picture and he had nine galleys and
i had like got my first relatively
recently
that reminds me of helping people do for
the thousand voices and then opening the
chest like i helped like a bunch of
exports people like i don't know when it
was like probably about a year ago and i
opened all the chests up they opened all
the chests up and i got like four of
them and i already had it and i was like
uh
guys sorry they kept you got it
i never even got it i was like what is
happening jesus you're like trying to
move the chat dialogue up so people
don't see that an exotic dropped
yeah
those were the days baby those are the
days
yeah well anymore that's kind of what
got me into destiny like
it's
it's
you know it's tried my patience i must
admit i think particularly in the last
couple of years or a year i think when
it's since it went to steam with the
hacker
there's only times when i feel raging in
the game is when i'm up against a hacker
or something yeah
it really it really gets me
um
i was like then don't play call of duty
apparently right now don't play
battlefield i saw already has hackers in
the beta like it's yeah they're
crazy fast i do have a random question
um
it referenced i think all of us here as
desi players at some point there there's
that point of frustration right there's
that point of you know what
i'm kind of out right now like could you
did you have a moment like that with
destiny and then if so what was the
moment you're like you know what
i'm not playing right now i'm i'm done
for right now i can't like what was that
moment for you i think um
was it warming around about then oh okay
okay i think i like i didn't mind the
expansion but i think like once i got
into it i was just like
it just felt a bit like
repetitive and stuff and i got bored
with the game at that point so i stepped
away from it i actually think sea of
thieves came out but out there okay and
that was that was like super interesting
to me
because it felt a little bit like
not like destiny but like a lot of the
aspects of social play and all that sort
of stuff yeah um so i went heavily into
cfes who did pirate legend and went
crazy
wow yeah athena level whatever it was as
well that's like a lot of hours
it was a love house yeah like i was
trying to balance destiny and see
thieves and then at one point i was like
you got to choose travis
sea this now is amazing as well
yeah i paused destiny for a bit there
yeah but a good
close to a year i'd say yeah and then i
came upside what was the what was the
comeback what pulled you back
was it forsaken yeah forsaken like
forsaken was like truly i think the best
expansion that destiny's ever done and i
know a lot of people say that writing
wasn't
amazing but
i think it was the
thing for me was doing this angle shawn
like that took a lot of time and then
the dream you see the surprise of the
dream is he and just
how
big it was and all the secrets and stuff
that was that was it that that had me
hooked up straight back in i was like
yeah this is truly great
although the other stuff that followed
like one-eyed mask and the supers
that was yeah but i mean
it was fun it was very seems like you
have some issues with the competitive
side of destiny
oh yeah well this is what i was saying
um yeah when we were chatting the other
week before
the waterfall incident happened
a waterfall incident
good to you i like that i played the pve
side of the game mainly for pvp oh
travis you hear this
oh i need it
like i i like the pve stuff but i feel
like it's got to the point where it's
and i think part of this is is the light
level as well the the creep there the
power cream but i feel like it just got
to a point where it doesn't feel
particularly challenging it feels like i
could almost go into pve with any gun on
really and just use abilities unless
they force you to use a certain gun yeah
you got champions that can only use
barrier auto rifles go well i have like
six choices
yeah although there's so many weapons
and
stuff that you can get around that now
you know there's just so many abilities
that you can just
just totally work them out but yeah so i
feel like pve
and they're obviously doing this what
they're doing like legendary stuff yeah
covering the exact term for it but in
which queen and beyond um so maybe
that'll get a bit more interesting but i
feel like they should just get rid of
power level and you know have have hard
activities and normal like that should
be the standard yeah that also helps
like if i bring new friends in
and they don't they don't have the grind
this power
to play an activity with me
yeah it's like i've been actually
playing a lot of new world yup i've been
chopping a lot of trees and everything
else so i have been playing a lot of new
world i checked my hours and i was like
oh crap i don't know how accurate it is
but it's probably
sadly not as far off as it should be um
but that is still one of those things if
i walk up to a level six enemy i just
one shot it and it's just like you never
get to do that in destiny you never and
that's when you say it's like getting
rid of the power level it's like in
theory they're as powerful as they want
you to be they're gonna cap you and
grandmasters like they're gonna always
have the delta working generally against
you and that's why occasionally you see
the people who are sitting there you
know doing the
what is it the shattered throne thrall
thrall hallway or whatever and they're
like level
you know plus 50 i'm like why there's
literally zero point the highest stuff
caps you like you want to do a mastered
nightfall easier that's the only thing i
can generally think of but other than
that
it is the weird thing about this like
you never get to feel over the top even
in the pve side even though as you said
you've grinded up this crazy power
theoretically in patrol you could still
die like and you should nuke everything
out there so it's always weird so i get
you on that one my clan mates call them
power or the bounty gremlins that's
for those people
yeah which is you know like i could
that that's the stupidity like
you could just sit there with your
computer overnight
afk
just in the freeway checkpoint just to
get just to get to the point to be able
to do
vault of glass master so yep which is
basically i've i've kind of had to do a
similar thing just to get that because i
didn't quite complete the seals that's
another thing i've got every seal in in
the game
you wow oh we ted we gotta call teddy up
we're gonna have to compete stats here
what's going on he's like teddy's got
everything else teddy got competition
teddy's got four more score he's a
little crazier but every single i don't
do that that's every seal is still no
joke because like that means you're
running raids in all the different
fashions and way that's everything man
that's legit i do like every pretty much
every day one right if if it depends
like if there's stuff going on at work
then obviously i don't
um but like i'll do it in the first week
at least anyway
xbox and destiny raid come out in the
same day what do you do
that was actually troublesome
for the export series x because they
both they launched at the same time as
beyond like yeah so
right um
yeah that was yeah that was that was
that was difficult
it's like it was a tough week i don't
want to talk about it yeah lots of sleep
has not had yeah yeah yeah absolutely
the one that i'm always jealous
it's the one that she got for doing all
the activities with um
oh scourge of the past
yeah that raid that was that was serious
i forgot the name of it now but it was a
lot
yeah and my brother was like oh i had i
have to do a flawless raid and he just
was like nope
yep
blacksmith there's like some that are
called like flawless and unbroken and
you want to be like a tradesman
nobody is so rare yeah but some sound
cool like there's one that's like
flawless so i figured at some point
we're gonna have like a godly type title
like it's a bit like over the top for
what you're trying to say is like i'm
god cool yay it's like the blacksmith it
just like it sounds cool so i was like i
understood my brother for that one but
yeah one that's not in the game though
um iron lord like why is
banner they they use him enough to like
fill space and time give us a seal to
chase give us a title get yeah like that
seems like a no-brainer
yeah literally in the intro saladin
who's long overdue for an update i threw
it in there because again every time he
comes back it's just oh get some
bounties done cool
i remember claiming like 5 000 tokens uh
for the reese walker recently and i
still didn't get goldwell oh my god i
was like
how many how many did you get in that
number of tokens like how many roles did
you get not even that many i think like
less than 10.
yeah wow
and the way trials got redone recently
that minimum needs to happen at an iron
banner alone but something cooler would
be nice but yeah if nothing else a
little more directed grind would be good
especially now that they've done this
weird split where like you you have to
play iron banner now because on the
weekend there's no trials when that
week's on it's just really i don't know
i was like i know we we had a pretty
heated debate when paul was on it got
quite like spicier than ever if anybody
listened to that one
uh it was all in fun by the way so it's
like some people like i was like hey we
had fun devil's advocates it's always a
good time but i have never in my life
when iron banner was here over the
weekend been like
kind of wish trials was here too yeah
like i'm sorry who am i
yeah yeah
that was gonna happen
it's a fun luke right now isn't it like
they've made it more i mean it's
obviously
pretty much
you know my man could probably go
flawless now though that's the problem
it's so easy well that doesn't put me
very high then if your nan's going i
gotta step my game up because she's
beating me so don't underestimate the
fans first of all yeah but it's yeah it
is it's very easy it's she's like an
elite gamer in game activity as we as we
discussed
tom's nan is a mlg pro he just doesn't
tell anybody yeah for my halo pro
yeah i was gonna say so we actually are
at a really good time to talk about
basically we've got a full the delay
actually worked i know thank god
everything works still but the week
delay works we actually finished our
quest
so i wanted to touch because we didn't
get to talk last week
about like the conversation everybody
was dreading
and then this week kind of wrapping
everything up with the shattered realm
and actually getting all the witches
and kind of i wanted to see where you
guys landed in tom techians sorry [ __ ]
call them witches okay that's like
they're tech witches
bro
it's like calling that's what i call
tuscan raider sand people okay
all right so we're gonna go with
techians anyways uh we have seven of
them sitting there mars still sitting
over there at a console twiddling our
thumbs waiting but anyway we did finish
the quest i wanted to ask you guys where
you kind of stand after last week
experiencing the conversation seeing how
everything went down getting like the
interaction with the like the intercom
console thing
uh tom just because you are a guest i
wanted to get your thoughts on it first
as we kind of did finish the
story beats at least for a little bit
yeah i think it's it's good that crow
finally knows who he who he is like i
don't know how he didn't know anyway
because surely someone should have told
him we found out
i don't know we were only allotted seven
words per uh season
so
we couldn't explain it in that oh yeah
yeah
we don't talk do we twitter twitter
limit is too small
yeah and so it's it's good that they
finally finally done that but now it's
opens up the question of like
where's crow you know where does crow's
story go like i know i think a bunch of
people think he's gonna they're gonna
kill him off um i just don't i don't see
that he'd do that like why would they
build up that story and then just kill
him off
he's gonna be the reason
escape so so that's kind of yeah like it
seems like um but do you think the queen
or severfoone will turn him back
like
a lot of good questions here a lot of
good questions um
i think he's definitely too busy being
dead
[Laughter]
that's my theory we'll get to it but
he's gonna be there so she might not die
now i'm wondering about that
right someone's gonna die though right
this season yeah
sure
yeah he's got eight he's got this yeah
he's got a minimum osiris he's gonna say
he's got eight legs i think that guy's
dying
yeah
oh yeah like i'm glad they
but then now that that part of the
story's finished and you know we're kind
of waiting to see what happens with
cyberphone and stuff
what what what are we doing for the next
yeah the marathon halo throwback bungie
dungeon
and then you're like wait this isn't
destiny i'm playing halo infinite right
now whoops
but like they're they're writing and
like going back to when destiny first
launched like the way they had to like
split that up and the writing and it was
all i think i never really followed the
story properly at the beginning to be
honest because it was it was very
confusing very convoluted it was yeah um
but they're writing over the past year
especially like here's been it's been
very good um they finally gave those uh
those those grimoire writers a job on
the game that's what it seems like yeah
because like writing has always been so
good and then you look at the writing in
the game and you're like really i don't
have time to explain why i don't have
time to explain this is awful
who is writing this stuff so
yeah
and like
but do we think crow will be the hunter
vanguard
i think so
i think so i think i kind of think so
yeah it's it's i i'll jump in i think
it's
they want this position to be earned
that's the vibe i get from the writing
team they they
in some long roundabout way because they
have literally delayed this
you know story for so long the 100
vanguard has has been absent obviously
since kade's passing
and it needs to be filled but you know
it is interesting the route they're
going because i'm with you tom
i i i'm very curious especially with the
way things have ended now he's been you
know he's been revealed which is rare
like no one generally knows their past
life you know prior to a guardian now
that he has that information what turn
does that make what turn does it
ha what happens because he clearly
looked at sabathune slash osiris as this
father figure right so
you know is he gonna do something rash
also right so it's very interesting to
see i wanna know where they go how is
this
going to transition with him
specifically
into which queen that that's the
interesting part and the last part i'll
say is that um
you know the vibe they've given us with
the with the techians and like now the
ritual to exercise the worm you know
savvithun is crystallized hilarious
conversation with a sabbath dune and
mara i thought like i thought she was
like south dew was just digging and i
thought she was the smartest in the room
i thought she was this i thought she was
there shut up shut up i like that i just
like the cat fight going on between
those two it's a lot of posturing but um
you know at the end of the day i i do
want to see because they've alluded that
while this ritual is happening
that we're going to have to protect it
because ziva raft is going to try to
somehow interfere and interrupt but yeah
i i'm very curious how
what is crowe's role
with this situation and eventually in my
opinion how does he
become hunter vanguard and if that title
happens in which queen or whatever what
do you guys think
travis is shaking his head
i think they're done with the vanguard i
honestly think that they're telling you
like like think just they're sort of
deconstructing all of the old stuff like
they got rid of factions and sort of
like one sentence and last season and i
i don't think that they've really been
concerned about who the hunter vanguard
is because the vanguard has sort of been
irrelevant for a long time i think
vanguard's probably the next thing to go
from the game like it's it's not going
to matter when the darkness is killing
everybody like who has the office job
with the title you know what i mean are
you saying it's going into the content
that's right we'll get there in a second
yeah i really i really would be
surprised if they were like all right he
gets this official title and this role
and responsibility i just think
destiny's beyond that point where like
you're chilling at the tower and like
people are giving you orders and stuff
like that i think it's just going to be
like
after sabbath and it's gonna be like all
right we're in the final stretch here
like things are chaotic we're fighting a
war like it's not like who cares who's
doing what at the tower um and and i
would be surprised if a lot a lot of
people said like oh my core might die in
the next um next season or whatever i
don't think that's probably gonna happen
but i do think that uh the old model for
how things have existed in destiny isn't
gonna be relevant anymore that'd be my
guess anyway
yeah that's interesting i wonder like
there's always been leaks about the
tower changes and stuff like i wonder if
we're finally gonna see that get blown
up or something see that's what i guess
i was wondering about too because travis
was saying something about the vanguard
and
we'll get into it when we talk about the
destiny content vault of what's leaving
but i sat there and i stared at the helm
when i was getting ready to like make my
video for that and it's like
there's a lot of things in here and a
lot of characters based around this
season are any of those gonna stay and
there was this rumor somebody got into
like the modeling or something like the
game files of spoiler warning by the way
that i have no idea of this is anything
but it was like the idea that the helm
was like this detachable ship i feel
like i heard that at some point like the
helm is actually something that could
like
you know be potentially and it's on the
director as its own note at this point
correct might just not be connected to
the tower anymore on grounded it could
be something that actually like floats
or something like so it's like if it
ever got to that point and that's just
kind of like you know where we do things
from going forward if the tower gets
blown up something happens who knows
um i could see that kind of happen at
least it feels like they set up a little
[ __ ] like basically because you got a
vault in there you got a postmaster you
got a little bit of it you just need
like rahul in the corner next to crow or
something like that but outside of that
you can probably find places for most
people in there
and it would give them a way to
kind of do something drastic to the
tower again kind of as we've been
through before yeah which again is
travis would say it's a good theory
it would be nice because i'm i've been
confused why there's basically two
towers and one of them is useful and one
of them's not useful like that's
having to do the whole back and forth
don't you yeah
especially for prime yeah for prime
engrams it's annoying i got to keep
going about it
so yeah just all that combined so i'd
like to see some big shift like that if
we're going into this
finale trilogy for the saga of light and
dark and all that stuff that they're
going through if they do something like
a tower shift up going in like sabathun
does something crazy i don't know but
that would be kind of a nice way to as
travis said like have the vanguard
maybe they're not as important and it's
more of kind of this combination of just
like allies as opposed to a vanguard
having any power authority it's just
like guardians cabal
uh methorax and the house of light and
just all of the forces that are working
with us
somehow have a place to meet and all the
npcs are in one area and you're not
running around this crazy big tower for
kind of no point half the night i gotta
go do something gambit like i already
don't like going to gambit why do i have
to run all the way down there just to go
talk to the drifter anyway it's like
are we ever gonna get more out of that
guy his lines are always hilarious but
he's just sitting down there and kind of
uh you know
the bottom of the barrel of the tower
so it's just interesting if if the helm
floats like say it's floating then this
should bolt onto it and what this is is
more vault space
please yes i i am the worst on that one
i have an emote i literally have an
emote on twitch that is like my
cheetah's eyes like peeking out through
a whole bunch of engrams i finally had a
jojo make that one because yeah my vault
my postmaster my characters everything
is my vault space and it's i never have
enough fix collections just fix coins
well that would help too don't worry
don't worry about vault space just just
let us delete it um like say i've got a
hand cannon i've i've killed that roll
off i could just build it again yeah
collection yeah that'd be interesting
just let's do that should be able to
designate a raw for all of your weapons
and armor like as long as you've picked
as long as you've actually got that
wrong
required you should have to re-recreate
yeah yeah yeah
if they did collections right i don't
even think we would need a vault like at
all yeah exactly maybe maybe for a few
extra rolls that aren't in your your
collection role but i know that the the
vault space is specifically on the
technical side it's actually tied to
like
memory on the consoles yeah it's like
they say that but i was like the ps4 got
to be able to manage a little bit and i
know we'll get in all the technical
we're going to get into the technical
discussions because we have some
opinions about all that stuff here so
i guess this probably works as good a
segue as any when it comes to technical
space
we got to talk about this because they
dropped to the twa but they dropped
something before this yesterday and it's
all about the update to the destiny
content vault and there are opinions to
be had on twitter if you look for them
it's not too hard to find them
um
and it really is a question of
kind of what everybody every time this
comes up it's always like this debate of
like the technical limitations over what
they're trying to do and they go through
it all and they even have said in the
top of it before we cover what's coming
what's going
um
i just want to read the top so you have
this in the back of your mind because
this is where bungie is coming from as
to the why they do this
so they say last summer we introduced
the destiny content vault as part of our
commitment to the future of destiny 2.
the dcv was created to help us achieve
our vision for the game through our trio
of upcoming expansions and beyond which
they keep hinting at by cycling select
content into the dcv the team has been
able to focus on bringing you new
activities and adventures at an
incredible pace with weekly updates that
introduce new gameplay wrinkles new
activities to enjoy and that pushed the
destiny narrative forward
the impact of the dcv can be seen
throughout destiny 2 from very popular
new activities such as battlegrounds
that have persisted throughout year 4 to
innovations that have made the routine
experience from destiny better for every
player for example the dcv has provided
a great deal of technical breathing room
that the team has devoted to im
important improvements in to the destiny
experience upgrades such as drastically
reducing our patch response times
improved loading times quicker access to
the ui such as your inventory or the map
and others link directly to the
opportunities that dcv has created for
the team today we wanted to give an
update on our content strategy for the
near future of destiny 2 and pave the
way for the witch queen expansion
so there's they want to give the
technical reasons as to why
but even before i get into what's going
on with what's coming and going i know i
wanted to start with cog on this one
because the technical
stuff you were talking to someone
specific about this and there's debates
about other games and things of that
nature so i know you were talking to a
friend of yours and
there's debates about if this is
required what other games do so i wanted
to give it to you just because i knew
this is kind of something you were
itching to discuss so you're up first
sir appreciate it yeah i mean this is a
this is a hot one i want to shout out
the amazing hoglaw you know and i want
to shout out my boy dom he's a financial
analyst as well on twitter good follows
and you know it's a point of contention
and and right now
the issue comes down to obviously the
reasoning
why they're saying they're doing it you
know we obviously we had the dcv
introduced to us
you know right before that i believe it
was a startup beyond light i'm to say
right so um yeah right around beyond
light we were told the reasoning that we
were told the game size is getting too
big we were told that they would also
reprise older destinations
and bring them back and then you know we
had we lost weapons and so on and so
forth and we were told things would be
introduced then at that point things
were
quote unquote reintroduced from the
weapons standpoint but not at the
frequency that the destiny community
liked we felt there was a disparity the
sun setting kind of went away and then
you know here we are so at the end of
the day is two trains of thoughts here
you know hog
start is he does not believe
in the reasoning that you know there's a
technical limitation or reasoning and
that
at the end of the day
the argument is no other game
takes away content
and then
you know makes you continue to pay
it's it's it's something that is
not really if we look at other if we
want to call destiny and mmo or mmo
light or whatever that it's not equated
and then you know to dom's point i was
looking at the very amazing argument on
twitter you know he was just like look
you know who am i to say that obviously
they've introduced new content
consistently
and you know they're saying the reasons
why and then we talked about the tiger
engine right this engine that has been
around
from its inception and me you e you know
obviously before travis we've had this
conversation as well as far as you know
the desire
to update it because we're not going to
say a spaghetti code going on right we
don't know the the aspects of it but the
desire
for it to
you know be updated so maybe they don't
have these technical issues maybe we can
get dedicated servers so
that's kind of the basis of it i i want
to i have my thoughts on it but i want
to just kind of that's really what the
art is because people are people are
shout out to my editor-in-chief i got a
shout out about josh joshua from lords
of gaming.net you know he's very animate
he's like this is a mistake you know
getting rid of the tangled shore and you
know it's a very passionate art people
like no other games doing it but
bungie's hustling us and you know then
right then there's the other side you
know that is like yo other games you
know have done this and this is not as
big a deal and people are
fear-mongering you know saying so i will
bring it to y'all that i'm gonna say my
thoughts but that that's kind of what's
going on it is a there is a legit
civil war i guess going on with this
topic may not be quite as dramatic but
travis i know shaking his head over
there so he's got a thought yeah
so first like not only have other games
done this but almost every game does
this now because
almost all games have an online uh
element and the online element
inevitably goes away when they take the
servers down like go try to play a game
like a call of duty from like 10 years
ago like the servers won't be live you
won't be able to access any of those
maps or play the game like part of the
user agreement now is that games change
i also don't really like the argument
that like no other game does this or
that they've not seen this in the past
with older games because like the the
genre of gaming is changing dramatically
and the stuff that destiny is doing with
like seasonal content and that sort of
stuff like that's sort of a new model
and there's not really an answer to it
like older games were maybe coming out
with one or two expansions like skyrim
and then and then not no more content
destiny has
new content every week like you can't
just put all that in the game so i will
say i agree with hogue that i don't i
don't believe the technical limitation
part i really don't i think it's
a matter of
i think it's more of a matter of
consolidating all of the players around
a couple activities rather than having
you know 9 000 activities and splitting
the player base like 50 different ways i
i don't think that that i think that's
probably the bigger problem when they
say technical limitation they're sort of
being intentionally vague because they
could do it it's more of a matter of to
them it's not worth it and the the um
the advantages outweigh like the
disadvantages but um i personally am not
a fan of like people taking away content
from people who've purchased it like i
100 get that argument i'm a reviewer so
like my job is to is to like speak on
behalf of the the player and i i don't
think that that's a fair deal but
i think um
there you can you can say that and then
you can also look at like fortnite and
the events that they do and you can't
replay those if you miss them they're
live events where you know the
the whole
universe gets sucked into a black hole
or whatever like
there's some there's some of destiny
that you're not really paying for you're
just getting you know what i mean and i
think that those things they have a
right to like remove from the game uh
obviously people did buy forsaken and it
sucks to see it taken out of the game
but bungie's also being pretty
transparent about it right they're being
like hey this is a decision we're making
we
told you that this was going to happen a
while ago we're now telling you ahead of
time so you have time to play it um
and also it's probably not forever
there's probably going to be like hey
remember forsaken a
call back where they take it out of the
content vault and they'll let you play
it again at some point in the future
do we really think we've seen the last
of it we all know how much destiny loves
reusing their old content you know like
do we really this is gonna be the last
time we played through the forsaken
campaign um so
uh i i i just think there's a little bit
of overreaction i 100 get why people are
upset because it's like the most beloved
campaign it breathed new life into
destiny just like the taken king did for
vanilla destiny one but um i i think
probably by the time we've played
through the new campaign we won't care
as much i have a question before we pass
it out
to time everyone um i don't play other
mmos so i i do have a question like
what game just for the sake of fitness
like what game has taken out content
that's kind of like either mmo or mmo
like i don't know i'm just i'm just
asking the two because the big ones that
i can think of like
final fantasy 14 is kind of a special
one it died hard
they have not world of warcraft has
started with like
i don't know how much i don't know if
they've ever actually taken out anything
that they've added now they have
probably gone through and they've done
the cataclysm where they've like
reworked areas right they've never like
gone through and stripped campaigns to
my understanding like right if you go
level one to 60 in world of warcraft i
don't know if that experience is exactly
the same it might be more streamlined
but i know there's definitely been
variations of like the witch queen added
an eye like not witch queen sorry wrong
game um
what am i thinking of now what's the
snow one it's like
lich king i wasn't far
there you go very close yeah the wrath
of the lich king that was in like the
wintry area like that was a bigger piece
too and they added stuff and i know
cataclysm came through and took the two
main worlds and like drove half a
volcano up the middle of them so i mean
they revamped stuff
okay but it's like to take
and it's different for me
i guess i'm going to just steal my time
here anyway
yeah but it's like
final fantasy 14 to my understanding
like what is free in that game is the
initial like campaigns and expansions
that you go through and you can play
like 100 hours or something is my
understanding there and then you can
finally get into what's current which
you can actually pay for and then like
end walker's coming this year which is
supposed to be apparently a huge thing
as well but 14 has
the whole thing that you can play for
right start so finished so the question
is there
right and and the guy
the caveat there is that it's a terrible
experience
is irrelevant but the question is is it
there or not i'm saying it's bad because
they haven't taken it out like if you
want to play with your friends the
process is all right catch up on a
hundred hours of gameplay right so
imagine that in destiny right like that
would be an awful experience and so i
think it's just different ways of doing
it like in final fantasy they're like
all right you want to play current play
every single campaign it's mandatory
we're not taking out of the game and
some people have myself included because
i don't have that kind of time wish that
they would have just locked that off
gotten rid of it and let me give me a
way to kind of jump to the current stuff
and so that that's why i bring it up i'm
not talking about the the content being
bad actually the final fantasy campaigns
are pretty good in final fantasy 14. i
just mean the experience of catching up
is awful
in final fantasy yeah so that's kind of
the thing for i was just going to say
for me
is
picture the new player experience being
even more disjointed than it already is
when they strip out forsaken
because now you have crow you don't even
get to see his backstory because you
can't play the campaign and if they use
him as a character going forward
that is a piece of the story like you
can't play the red war campaign anymore
we already know that's gone
and then you've also got now the
forsaken campaign which is one of the
coolest ones with the barons the fights
the tangled swords going to be gone i
understand like if they're going after
technical pieces where it's like hey we
have to debug that this weapon works on
all places for some reason this weapon
breaks like has a game crashing bug now
when you go play the forsaken campaign i
get those pieces
but it's the experiences that they built
that new players won't be able to
experience like as you said travis if in
14 you have to play 150 hours to play
with your friends that's not the best
if there's like a streamline button to
catch up to friends that would be good
but the fact that
you can't understand you can't go play
the backstory that other people have
because it's gone that's i think the
part and the fact that they're still
selling it right now
when this announcement came out i feel
like and this is gonna open up another
point i feel like it should be live or
free today
i mean they're gonna make the forsaken
camp and the raids are gonna be there
and dreaming city is gonna be there but
it's also three years old at this point
like if you're gonna give people five
months or you're gonna give the campaign
in three months i feel like the whole
thing should be free at this point
forsaken it's old enough but like hey if
you come play destiny right now you can
experience the forsaken campaign and
everything the dream city has to offer
for free and you're still gonna then buy
the witch queen for a hundred dollars
which is plenty of stuff that's gonna
help i just don't think having forsaken
sitting on steam right now for 25 is a
fair dollar amount at all at this point
because that's for sure that's too much
somebody said they bought it for like
eight bucks on twitter i was like oh
yeah keep that that's fine but like
25 bucks that doesn't seem right to me
at this point as it has an end date that
is not you know it's less than six
months away and it's just the fact that
like it's one of the coolest stories in
destiny that we got to see with cade go
away it's kind of his send off sorry
spoiler alert if you're too late to that
one but also the fact that you get to
see like the barons and crow you get to
see him uh riven all of those pieces
that are now actually coming into a real
important piece of the story right now
you have no way to go back to that and i
know we're not going to be able to go
back in to do the raid right the raid
will be there last wish will exist
that's going to be even more out of
context than it is now all right let's
get let's get started yeah sorry it's
like i know we rambled but i was like
yeah we ran we got to get our themed
guest
i think this all comes down to a couple
of things how you value uh personally as
a player um and then
bungie's business models which are a
little bit hectic for for destiny
um because you are
paying for dlc content and then you are
paying for like a battle pass
essentially um and i don't think you can
really have both these days
and micro transactions yeah
i think this whole like mixture this
hybrid of like revenue um opportunities
for them
like they obviously they wanted to go
free to play um the activision split
whatever all that sort of stuff we don't
have to go into that but they obviously
had a particular direction where they
felt like they could monetize the game
and perhaps it hasn't really fully gone
one way or the other and they they kind
of still trying to work out the revenue
mix um and i think that's the tension
that we're seeing in the game over over
the past sort of a couple of years or
whatever
i mean that's the biggest problem at the
moment they need they need to figure
that out because when they're doing this
content voting thing it it it feels like
they're taking content away from you
but on the flip side it's how do you
value that content um like if i go to
the cinema i see a james bond film and
then three years later it's on tv i
don't go i was ripped off you know like
that's you know it's on tv for free like
i don't do that right like because i've
had those at that at that hour
three hours of fun and i've experienced
that um and then i've forgotten about it
i might not i might want to watch it
again maybe um but i might not and i
think that's the kind of same here in a
sense um
like i don't go on to tangle sure much
i'm not gonna miss that i have the
memories of that and and it was great
and the amount of hours that i've got
out of that whatever 30 bucks was like
hugely valuable for me so i don't i
don't feel like i own that um and that's
another point is that
you don't
i think if you're playing destiny you
feel like you own the content you're
going to go play in 10 years you're
going to come back to it you're playing
the wrong game if you if you have that
approach to this game really because
it's just kind of not what the game is
but bungie's never really truly
like that like forsaken is is a good
part of this because that was where they
kind of really tried to adapt to this
whole live game you know like they said
the world's gonna change
it has and it hasn't no like they
haven't really built upon that they have
a lot of promises you know like
like we said earlier there's always a
promise for this game but they haven't
really fully gone in one direction or
the other and it speaks to me there must
be internal
you know struggles like directors want
to go one way um
and all of that sort of stuff
um and i think they need to figure all
this out like they need to figure out
their revenue they need to figure it out
but i don't think it's necessarily a bad
thing the content fault i think players
just need to understand the type of game
that they're actually playing um right
and like like travis said he
like the xbox is great for backwards
compatibility i can go and play a you
know
call of duty game from 10 years ago 360
game i can yeah but the servers don't
really work properly and the game just
is not great experience it's like i've
missed that time to really
play the the great aspects of that game
and that's definitely going to be
destiny like even also like the stuff's
just all going to be missing and the
content's not there um
but yeah like
i think that bungie just needs to be a
bit more clear about their direction um
i spoke to like joan the guys a few
weeks ago um what was the one
yeah like we talked about a few of these
issues particularly the new player
aspect because i feel like that's
they've really screwed that up yeah
that's what i was gonna go next yeah
yeah like that's one of the probably the
worst parts of this game is that we can
all sit here we we know the game we love
the game we've played hours and hours
but like if you're new to this game you
get thrown in it's really hard to play
absolutely so hard to understand the
stories like all over the place that's
going to get obviously worse as content
gets removed
oh
oh he's back okay
like he's like that's me what's
happening no you're good no water the
water the water is good
yeah so that's obviously going to get
worse um and like how do they tackle
that and they've spoken about how
they've been able to afford to do like
really great content um like dungeons
and stuff just through basically selling
like skins and stuff which is great like
i don't mind that stuff's in the game i
don't mind that people buy stuff to
customize i mean that's that's a good
model um
but
they need to work out what they want to
do
do they almost want to charge us monthly
to play this game like is that what's
going to come up
yeah yeah like stop just stop charging
into all these different places like
figure out where you actually want to
make money and that one of the points i
made to joan i was like please just like
start selling emblems in the store like
have have a create a driven experience
where i can create an emblem as a
community member and sell that you take
a car well that's because they really
one thing that they really do well is
like they demonstrate in the twab every
week people's artistic skills and the
creators and the community stuff but
they never really pick up on that social
aspect of the game enough and bring it
into the game you know like it's like
dim's a third party thing like all these
really cool experiences out of the game
that help you play the game
are never really in the game like they
don't really embrace them enough um
yeah have i gone again oh we lost them
yeah he's in the shadow
[Laughter]
here hold room one second let me see if
i can switch our discord server to see
if i can get us a little more we're
doing that live oh no
everybody hold on
more water on the podcast no
all right we'll try that yeah i'm gonna
switch in the middle i put it to the
east coast so okay so
west coast okay
okay that's what it would yeah because
it was central that's where i'm at
because i sit between these two
yeah that is what i mean
i'm
there was a lot there a lot of cans i
just opened but like i think that it
that
the way that they make money in this
game is the core
thing and like like you said you don't
like someone doesn't believe the
technical aspects nor do i like
i i do to a certain extent so um their
engine is a little dated i think we've
seen that um they haven't
they're
as a team
they clearly haven't and i don't want to
be rude about like you but they clearly
don't really have any idea how to build
a game for pc
um because they obviously had vicarious
visions doing that before sure they've
really struggled and obviously the
anti-cheat kind of you know speaks and
speaks itself
oh yeah are you implying that there was
an issue with cheating on pc thomas are
you implying no that was funny
but there's just so many little things
like even like the siva files sometimes
corrupt
basic just basic stuff um right and it
is there's obvious like missed
opportunities there and just missing
knowledge um there
and i think that all just adds up and i
i feel like they just they just need to
work out like how they're gonna make
their money out of this game going
forward and like where it's gonna go so
yeah the model this is interesting
because again for me it's just there's
two trains of thought and selfishly as a
hardcore destiny player
i don't care about the title short
anymore honestly i would be brutally
honest like when the news came out
i shout out to tassie who we've had you
know the week before
in my mind
my you know the dreamer city was out of
here i was like damn they probably gonna
wrap up the story savathuna is connected
to to to the dreamer city
and personally the dreamers city hits
hard for me because i think you even
said it at one point tom where you know
you're playing forsaken and let's be
real the thought was the barons we're
gonna be stuck in tango shore and then
this magical thing happens with this
talisman you you unlock it and you're
into this beautiful world of the
dreaming city and in my opinion it's the
best play space they've ever created the
best sandbox from a visual standpoint
aesthetic standpoint the raid the
connection the the the cycle of the
curse
like it is truly a spectacular thing the
music the chants it's just beautiful i
just love
that space so
for me
i'm like okay
they're keeping that
and then i'm like all right why do i
still go to the tango show today again
this is selfish cognito this is selfish
i i'm just tell you right now i don't go
there unless it's for spider like i'm
like okay spider what's the exchange
rates today
all right glimmer all right who is this
spiral spin metal shards you know what
i'm saying so
that was really my only thing so when
i'm hearing that it's going to raul's
responsibility rest in peace fight i
don't know what's going to happen to you
but they don't look good
yeah so for me i'm like cool but then i
said all right cox stop being selfish i
know you play this game every day but
there are new players right and the only
thing it sucks what kind of leads me
back to what he is saying which is
this is really terrible for a new player
like for a new player
you literally have no idea of crow's
development you know for a new player
the connection to the story who crow
becomes the whole history of aldrin
that part sucks and even prior to what
he said he saw a point made another good
point which is the red war campaign
right there's really no way to replay
these narrative beats and that's the
struggle like how do they do that i've
heard suggestions of like well maybe
it's some like offline downloadable
thing and you know i i don't know the
technical solution i don't know how they
can fix that and it's just they're in a
tough spot they're in a tough spot
because there's there's the other part
that i will defer i'll give it back to
your topic because i don't want to come
the um the other part that i do
empathize with them
is when you have a character like crow
to me it is a disjointed narrative
experience when we're talking to the
crow right and we're doing this but if i
go to the tangled shore he's still in
there in the back
with the old suit not realizing he's
crawl right so it's just this
disjointedness
and they they they they're in a spot but
i'll give it back to you talk you seem
like you wanted to comment on that yeah
i wanted to pick up on like the the
technical stuff of like yeah i've got
all of this um
like i don't believe it's like fully
technical so if if it was like game size
for example you could just take it out
and make it an optional download like
there's easy ways to do that right like
i mean i'm not saying it's easy but it's
just
if it was purely there are ways yeah
yeah like like wall zone did that um
i don't think it's that but what do you
think is it is
part of their engine um and like i think
it's still on like some i comment what
the name is but it's
halo yeah it's still like a halo reach
level sort of engine right
um
and i think it's scaled relatively well
but it's showing its age um and i think
some of the stuff they want to do the
game like i'm sure they'd love to do ray
tracing in this game
like imagine like it looks great even
without it but can you imagine what it
looked like with it like
it would be probably the best showcase
that we've had for that um
so in order to do that sort of stuff you
can't have all these planets that people
spend you know an hour on a month just
hanging around that they have to go and
update like we've seen them do this with
with maps and uh like in multiplayer and
they bring about the maps and they look
amazing compared to how they used to do
yes obviously because they've updated
for the their engine
um
and so yes they might bring this content
back eventually but i think it's more a
conscious fact of like like someone
tweeted me yesterday they're like i
can't believe this uh
and i was like when's the last time
you're on the tangle shawl and they were
like i spent five hours in the tower
sure yesterday so i was like you know
stalk a hat on that's like destiny
tracker yeah
people think they they really like need
this content
because they have that emotional
experience i could actually do it yeah
which is fair enough but like i think
it's like anything in destiny like
there's an emotional part of the
community who reacts and then in a
year's time everyone will forget because
the experiences they're having right
then will be like
all right so much better i won't push
back for jokes on one thing though
we gotta we gotta rest in peace to one
of the greatest lost sectors
ever
the
next to the helmet tower or something
like that they're in the last city
just this is like it's always a shame
when this stuff goes i believe
so okay let me cover what's actually
leaving the game
sorry what staying no and then we'll
kind of kind of break down what the
nostalgia hits are actually going to be
so beginning in february basically
tangled shore
whole destination is going there
uh most things with the year four
seasonal content are going so you can
picture
the
expunge missions override missions we've
got
exotic quests sadly presage is one that
hurts for me you've also got harbinger
you've got the whole tangled shore
destination including the hold strike
you've also got the hollowed lair going
away we are keeping warden of nothing
that one is staying but tangled shore
will no longer be there so it's just
gonna kind of be dumped into the
vanguard list which we'll talk about in
a second
um
i've also got the kudegara mission out
there in the dreaming city that nobody's
probably done in ages that was from uh
the high celebrant hunt we're gonna be
missing now shattered realm we're gonna
be losing the astral alignment missions
and i don't even know what the helm is
going to look like that's kind of one
big question as well
but yeah the tangled shore is gone and
pretty much everything in year four
minus battlegrounds which are going into
the vanguard strikes playlist as the
vanguard operations playlist which
that's a positive i know that'll give
some you know variety at least in that
playlist because there's four of those
in there so if you do run strikes you're
like oh it's not a strike it's got a
little thing so that will be a positive
so we're keeping battlegrounds keeping
warden of nothing
and
i feel like there was one other major
piece i'm forgetting for what's staying
but
most of year four in the dreaming city
and all that stuff yeah the dreaming
city is staying yeah right it's that
destination
oh no we lose do we lose the raid or not
the dreaming city is staying complete
dreaming city stays as is the only thing
you're going to lose from there is like
astral alignment and the coup de grace
basically the two seasonal things that
we've got from this year but the actual
city the destination the raid the
dungeon secrets all of the dreaming city
is actually going to stay around
gotcha can i completely derail this
conversation yes i'm a little worried
but go for it
i see some people in the comments
talking about the future work gear and
can i just say that's something that
needs to go into the content of all the
future war cult i was in the tower this
week and i saw some hunter with a future
volk cape and i was like oh my god
that's you might as well
uh have the confederate flag on your
back over there like
wow
these guys these guys seceded from the
vanguard and you're walking around this
cave that's a hate crime sir
so
yeah i'm going to go to the tower and
there's going to be a statue of lakshmi
and i'll be like what we're in town
square
statue locks me here
i'm gonna start a protest take down the
watchmen the statue
anyway sorry i just have to say if you
were if you were a future war cult i
judge you
you're treading on my people's culture
and i i'm very upset
oh you've done it they should at least
turn the lights off they should at least
turn the lights off in the futuristic
coffee shop up there should they should
probably turn those lights off because
that one's the evil starbucks in there
the evil starbucks
the coffee shop where all the meetings
went down
um
i'll start just before everything goes
leaving oh we're keeping the proving
going straight because that's over on
nessus as well so that's kind of
battlegrounds related anyway
out yeah he's like you know what it's
necessary
or the tower and if it went down to two
it would be the base code for destiny 2
is hidden in nessus for some reason you
have to keep the destination or delete
the entire tiger engine that's the one
i'm like yeah would be bad if you went
like i'm like what it's still here like
what are we really honestly though
seriously
what's on nessus still
from uh either exotic quest or there's
no raid there anymore what's that
it's just like there's probably a decent
chunk it's a decent chunk of strikes i'm
sure because there's a certain number of
strikes that you will lose they're
keeping ward of nothing so we're really
only losing two strikes but the playlist
is actually getting the battlegrounds
put in so that playlist is actually kind
of getting a plus two
kind of surprisingly um yeah
i don't go to any of these planets
unless i'm forced to to get a godly
weapon so then go back into the crucible
tab
yeah most people don't have a reason to
go tom speaking to my speaking to my if
man after my own heart over here
like you're making me play gambit
[Laughter]
i'm sorry to derail i'm sorry i just had
to get my nestles
it's fair because that's a that's a
question um but with table chore going
away master hool is going to be your
currency exchanger so you're going to be
dealing with him a little more with the
prime engrams well i guess more reason
to go to the tower the one that hurts
for me the most and this is one i feel i
wish they could keep because for a
second when i thought like tangled
chores going away i was like and then i
figured out okay warden of nothing's
staying but that's kind of like vex and
cabal is like are they removing the
scorn but i was like it took me a second
i was like no the scorn are still in the
dreaming city they're in the loft sector
there's they're still somewhat around
they're not as much
uh because the hollowed lair has gone on
the whole area but
i was like so that's not it so if the
scorn are staying please can you just
put presage in legacy
like even harbinger i don't love as much
like harbinger's cool uh don't get me
wrong i kind of like what you do in
there but when you try and solo that
thing it's a pain in the ass
yeah but i mean let's go into spider for
glimmer though
now rahul is going to be sitting over
there on his pile of of glasses they'll
replace that and the little like clicky
weird noises he makes and stuff yeah
yeah he's a great actor that's the guy
from straight
thinks he'll survive like i think
despite i think mara is completely
underestimating the spire and and he'll
be fine that's fine
maybe he'll get away but they're
definitely setting up some way to either
kill him or send him off into like the
ether of like unknown story feature i
mean he ensnared a guardian and his
employee i feel like he's he's he's a
little craftier than she thinks
it could be i'm glad that they're
keeping himself dead so
last wish yes yes like dreaming city
stays yep
that's
so hard that destiny players had to run
into a wall to complete you know like
they couldn't actually do it
legitimately legit they had the little
cheat that the video and day one like
was they did it in like 23 hours and
something like
those like glads was like 18
and then 24 hours and two minutes is
always the infamous data so they were
the first two i think
so yeah there were not many the first
like last wish is the hardest one
they've ever done
i feel like for the forsaken era and and
that raid was like when destiny was more
difficult for pve yeah that was like
it's
and and a lot of that wasn't anthem
coming out of the time like i feel like
the team was like super like we need to
have the best content we've ever had
because we've got a challenge
when they have competition they do their
best work but that was also activation
multiple studios and that was like those
were the biggest seasons we ever got
because we got three raids we got three
big seasons i mean that was the biggest
year we're ever gonna have due to
obviously the scale of studios they had
helping so again when you say tangled
shore dreaming city you get the last
switch which is like the biggest raid
they've ever literally put together and
then you have the seasons of the forge
we'll skip over the drifter and then
also you got you know um opulence and
all that stuff you have three or eights
in a whole in one year it's like that
was insane yeah that that yeah i think
it was crazy
oh you think so
yeah this is when bungie becomes this
big exact division
a matter of time i mean actually yeah
may start falling apart at any point but
that's a discussion for a whole other
podcast anyway tom we interrupted you
i'm sorry
i should say that one thing that i
really would love for destiny to get
back to is like the secrecy
like
it kind of does ruin the game a little
bit yeah i but i loved it like when
there was a secret new area that came
out like a secret new exotic like people
would literally be calling me like dude
you have to get online like it's tuesday
or what just wednesday wednesday just
random points
um
and they tried to do that with bastian
do you remember yeah
they kind of tried to do it and it kind
of backfired because they'd already told
people they were gonna get bastion and
then yeah yeah it was like i've already
getting it like
a weird reaction point but
i'd love for them to try and do some
more of that because like processing
message was kind of like that yeah right
about it it's so good
yeah i think they'll probably continue
to do stuff like that but apparently
they have the technology to
like black out certain parts of their
code so it can't be designed i remember
they said that yeah
and i'm like why aren't you using that
why like why don't i know
yeah yeah before it's in there i agree
to me peak secret
was whispered all whisper was yeah that
was something special i mean e
your channel definitely benefited
uh you know offered your amazing guy to
help me but um yeah whisper was just
prime time it also came at a very very
low point yes yes it was like after war
mined and it was like a couple weeks
before
we started talking about forsaken as
like the next expansion yes yes i just
remember like the entire community was
like huddled around destiny for the
first time in a long long time super in
love with this new activity and then
everybody immediately after that was
like well i'm going to go pre-order
forsaken like that was the ultimate uh
push to pre-order forsaken yeah
originally it was black spindle wasn't
it back in the day
blacksmith yes yes
i agree it's the same sort of thing oh
yeah okay
yeah just
just the fact that you sign on and
something happened happening live it was
that it was that whole element right is
that yeah something had changed you
weren't expecting
yeah
right wrath of the machines where there
was that uh oh the thing was yes
the morse code that's amazing used to
have those little spirally things over
them and
they have people hunting in the woods
for their package
what was the time when when gladly spent
about three days without washing or
straight on the stream
every week right
probably yeah isn't that what i was
gonna say yeah that's what he does isn't
that well that's harder for himself
right was that quarters that he did that
quarters of time that he didn't say
we're trying to unlock a door i can't
mean but it was cool though
oh
season of worthy um that was the public
event farming they were doing to finish
up for uh rasputin no no no no he's
talking about um this the armory season
all the symbols
yeah the one that nobody knows that door
you'll be labs and all that right that's
it
that was justin and teddy like uh a year
ago we went back and we were like let's
go do that puzzle now that everybody
knows how to do it and it was still
really irritating we got through it but
it was like damn this is like even even
with a guide we were like this is not
that fun yeah yeah
mm-hmm
i think was it
labs somebody said in the comments yeah
yeah stuff like naomi labs does bring up
like the whole element of the destiny
community where it splits though isn't
it late into this is too easy or this is
too hard sort of conversations like
pve is always too easy i i do not
understand the dude
like teddy is one of those guys like
we've had teddy on the show a bunch he's
one of those guys who says like oh yeah
i'm one of the best pve players i got
like 63rd on on for you know the
forsaken last wish rate and i'm like
what is good at pve even mean like why
is that is there such a thing as being
good at pve like to me
it's like it's like bragging about like
rock paper scissors or like checkers or
you know it's just like is that even
like a competitive do people care about
that i don't know
but yeah that's not the same that's not
even close i knew that one's not even
close i'm
sorry the only thing that's competitive
about pve is speedrunning
and the speed running
like kind of gave up on destiny when
they when they did all the the sword
nerfs right yeah they got rid of the
nurse yeah get get rid of i would come
at our toxic guest and toxic co-hosts
i just want to know like if you say
you're good at pve tell me what you're
good at that makes you good at it
because i don't disrespect do you know
royalty do you understand who is
co-hosting this podcast do you not know
the shattered realm so what do you
flavor the whisper of the worm solo
flick do you not know what this man's
name was built off of do you understand
this is what i'm saying i got
over here i don't even say anything
you're about to transition itself i'll
just be silly no no no um
yeah you can be decent at pve i guess we
can get into a debate on another day but
yeah it's definitely not rock paper
scissors that's that's
that's a trash
you can
i think being good at pve right now
means like you're really good at
creating builds
because that's that's kind of that's
true they've like with all the different
mods that's kind of where they pushed it
towards so rather than rather than
knowing that you can weird little
intricacies of the game you can watch a
youtube video and then be the best
player at pve because you did a build
that you saw i just don't i don't get
what being good at pve means it just
seems like we gotta have to do some solo
dungeons i was like okay they're out of
pocket they're out of pocket today
all right
well back when you had to like i was
gonna feel like she'd learn how to how
to skate or like you had to learn how to
quick swap than being good at pve you
know
it's like there are technical skills
there's also people who low man stuff
like raids like yes i'm yeah there you
go uh
names up in the chat y'all esoteric
because qualified is good at pvp because
he will pretty much do anything pve yeah
but yeah esoteric like me to shame
go go try and follow one of his youtube
videos yes
he's not human i'm convinced he's that's
a that's a cyborg so that's not a person
well we haven't used an algorithm
we don't see him in his videos so he
could be in it could be yeah i've never
seen this man
he
yeah i don't know i don't know if i can
ever get him if i can ever get him on
the show i will but i just don't think
he would be a podcast i don't think he
wants to be on a podcast he doesn't talk
in his own youtube videos he esoteric is
just bungie's test algorithm
let's see how somebody like starts to
stop watch patches live and how long
until he's done solo in this one and
done okay we got an hour and 20 minutes
sweet
yeah
but yeah there is in my opinion there is
skill in pve it just depends on what
you're looking at skill whether it's low
manning a raid whether it's speed
running whether it's just the fact that
you're like you know going into an
activity with a bad loadout just to try
and you know make things harder on
yourself you know if you're soloing a
grandmaster nightfall that's no joke
granted i feel like it's a lot of
patience because the whole leveling of
destiny is a different discussion but
there are ways to be skilled in pve some
is patient some is learning the ai but
it's not
it's not nothing i would definitely have
to at least put my foot down there
anyway
i i will also say that there are people
who claim to be good at rock paper
scissors they have a world championship
and there's some guy who's one time
there's a guy who's won the world
championship of rock paper scissors like
seven times so like clearly there's some
skill i will say watching pvp pros play
pve is one of the funniest things ever
it's just hilarious
um so they do state for forsaken you
will be able to play the campaign for
free
from december 7th until february 22nd
when it launches so if you've got a
friend who hasn't played it yet tell
them to hold off
in weird combination though they are
going to sell a forsaken pack i don't
know how much it's going to be
forsaken pack will be available for
purchase so we're still buying things on
forsaken three years later i have an
opinion there if you can't tell
it will include access to the last wish
raid
shattered throne dungeon
as well as access to all of the forsaken
exotics for second pack will also
include three forsaken
ciphers which can be used to instantly
unlock your choice of forsaken exotics
they do not include the raid and dungeon
exotics so if you still don't have a
thousand voices you're not going to be
able to go to the kiosk and get it yet
which
i'll go to walmart and pick one up i
know i was i was hoping i said
uh they say if you do buy the forsaken
pack and you already own it you're gonna
just get the ciphers will be turned into
ascended shards
um
i just had a weird this
at some point forsaken should not be
something they're charging for in my
opinion like these last three months
i don't know it's like so i know vault
of glass is a free raid
i get that but at some point whenever
witch queen comes out that's no longer
going to be the pinnacle raid
it's going to be a free raid but it's
not the pinnacle raid but i think at
that point it's so old
i mean that's the point where you can go
look at final fantasy where you have
like
hundreds of hours of content that you
can go play for free it's like i don't
know if world has stuff for free that's
a whole different example but
i mean there's a point where i think
they've got as much out of that as you
probably need to
i don't know why they're still holding
on to charging for that one that one
feels weird to me i wanted to get you
guys thoughts on that one because in my
opinion forsaken should be free it's
three years old
what you think
tom i think destiny should be free right
like that's what's up
we don't understand the pricing model at
this point but that's a different
discussion but it literally does go back
to their pricing models they don't know
and where they make their money like
surely they could put something in the
store that would just make up for that
revenue i don't know like
there's not there can't be that many
people buying i i guess they kind of
force you into buying forsaken then and
that's where it feels bad i think is
they
you're like oh you want to play this
other cool content for a little while or
here's the campaign that's free well i
did the campaign what about this wish
dragon well you got a paper
like and then that's it's
it's in a weird place as you said like
the pricing they're doing in a lot of
places but this one i think
my opinion is like i think they've gone
a little too long on this one
when do you think they'll actually like
fix their pricey stuff though i i feel
like the light and dark saga once that's
done i thought they almost missed it
already to be honest
i just don't ever
i don't think yeah i don't think they
will
i don't know it just doesn't seem like
it it
it seems like wherever they can
whether they obviously have a certain
revenue stream through certain you know
dlcs and like it's a guaranteed revenue
so they can then invest into the game
and whatever else
um
but yeah like it just doesn't seem it'll
ever change well that was the thing too
about say you were in this season right
now and you want to go back and play
some of the other seasonal content
you're like well hunt wasn't that great
but you probably should play chosen
splicer was pretty good but
like you have to go you have to just go
buy the whole thing you can't even
piecemeal the seasons at this point
there's no
you know part accent it's just so
to their credit though what other game
can you play the seasonal content after
the season's over
i mean
that's fair to a point but it's like you
can't do apex seasons you can't do
fortnite seasons that have already
happened
no and and i get that the content's out
there but you can't
piecemeal it though
like you could have piecemealed it
throughout the year but you can't
retroactively go back and do the same
you can't just like i want to play
chosen
hell
they're doing it right
well i mean now with forsaken they're
doing it three years later no i just
mean it's like
it's weird where you can't just you
could win chosen started if you want to
play chosen you could pay the 10 bucks
and do it but if you get past that
season you can't retroactively go hey i
just wanted to play chosen there's some
cool stuff in here i want to play
you know pressage i want to get the dead
man's tail stuff like that
you can't specifically go back you have
to spend like the 30 now when this stuff
is kind of outdated it's just a weird
and we'll say it enough it's where it
turns it back yeah yeah and it all comes
back to that new player experience as
well like if i have a friend who
especially returning players
yeah like because there's a lot of
people that do that yeah they come back
and they're like so what do i need to
buy like what guns do i need to get and
then they're like oh i can't get this
gun so i don't own this thing and just
like yeah
what a mess yeah like yep i get it all
the time i literally
especially
when a uh
what you call a destiny was put in the
game pass
and i had so many people come to me [ __ ]
i know that [ __ ] game you love it i'm
gonna get in and then they get in and
they like wait a minute like how did you
guys get that cool gun with a horde how
do you get that i'm like oh that's tied
to season of this
you know what i'm saying and this is
tied to the season of that and whoa whoa
black i want 1k voices how do you get oh
you had to buy forsaken you had to do
the raid and you so it's just
and then we've always talked about this
e like the onboarding is just for a new
player
it i mean i know they've tried with the
cosmic drum i know they've tried this
new light experience but it's it's still
a struggle that's why my new things i'm
like oh let me introduce you to my
friendy boxes in this channel for
getting started like i have to literally
point them to a youtuber and say watch
this because the game is not doing the
job of really streamlining streamlining
the experience is what you're supposed
to do and yeah that's the that's the
thing
with the i know we're going to go back a
little second but that's the thing with
the with the narrative beats uh
especially also not having a red wall or
not having a forsaken and then being
thrust into a story and you really have
no context you really have no history
and
they're in a tough spot i don't even
know how to solve it because it's
that's these this weird hodgepodge of
things
you know
yeah if they fixed that like this game
would truly be massive like yeah i
i do do believe that because the gun
play
especially if you're a first person
shooter for hand you could go play apex
you can go play warzone whatever all
those but the gun play does never quite
feel the same even though it's still
peer-to-peer for some reason
even all this stuff that frustrates you
and all this stuff but like it's still
unrivaled like
it really is preach pretty speak your
true top piece speak to you
right they made it free to play and then
they just made the new player experience
terrible like how how does that happen
it's crazy yeah
it's it's almost like what you were
saying like the the friend game is the
end game and it's also the pre-game now
like that's the only way to get intro
into the game is to have friends who can
go through it and i think i think like
bungie at this point is like counting on
that like oh you're not gonna get into
destiny by yourself you're not just
gonna download it on game pass and
figure it out you're gonna like need to
know a guy yes destiny pops up and after
you get done with your quest with shahan
it's gonna say first go watch fast and
furious so you understand where this
reference came from second here's a four
and a half hour video from bife
yes go watch this get some popcorn hang
out and you'll catch up and then you can
go
but i was like how is i mean they've
started doing the animated storyboard
the inkblot like kind of stuff
they need somebody who's saying it chat
and i was chatting with them too they
need you to kind of go through the
basics and understand the fundamentals
and be like all right sit down you got
about 30 minutes of in-game cinematics
to understand what you've been through
as a player in a franchise the gods
we've killed the things we've done you
may not be able to experience this but
these are the things we've been through
in order to get to this point because
they want the friend to be able to jump
in now if they want a friend to be able
to jump out of the timeline they added a
time lapse which was impressive i did
like that you're getting a trap sorry
yeah yeah but it was like just gonna say
that yeah
no but yeah the timeline's there but it
is just
that some way in game for somebody to
just it doesn't have to be 30 minutes
that's extremely it's like just somehow
make us like a 10 minute like have
somebody build
a quick summation story so if you want
to jump into savathune you know why
we're here on year yeah
yes it's like like that thing when we
had destiny 2 launch and they had you
know if you signed in with a destiny one
account you saw yeah
yeah yeah
they definitely need that i mean they
need the opposite of that if you haven't
signed them here's the stuff
yeah here's what you missed and that
they should utilize that timeline that
they created right and there should be
those storyboard you know cinematics and
say hey this is what happened and you
know d from d1 all the way to where we
are now even if it's you know 15 20
minutes it'll have to be all day but
there should be a narrative beat
leading the player to say okay that's
who this crow is and oh you know just
they got to do something better with the
on boarding from a narrative standpoint
yeah and also if you return like i i
sign into account i haven't used for
like a year and it's just like
yeah that's all you get just a hundred
different things that mean absolutely
nothing it's not like oh so we see you
haven't played the game for like 12
months or whatever here's what happened
in the game up till now sort of thing
like that that would just be so good for
a returning player oh okay i understand
okay so then oh i can go get this weapon
yeah i just think they need to make a
new player experience and it needs to
evolve every season like
change change what what that new player
experience concludes every season and
just like keep it up and then
if they're going to keep charging us for
expansions which again i don't think
they should i think they should just
change their model it should be a free
game and they make their money in
microtransactions but if they're going
to keep charging you the destiny content
vault should be a separate app where you
can access legacy content like i know
that's been suggested before but like if
they're if they're pulling all the stuff
out and putting it somewhere else then
make their separate app where i can
access all of the old destiny campaigns
you're good yeah that's fine i was just
gonna say like
like if if they are taking it all out of
the game for technical reasons then make
a separate app where they're offline
campaigns or you can play with a couple
people and and that sort of thing and
yeah i just think they need to do that i
mean i think you actually had a selling
i think you had a really good idea what
the timeline is depending and it could
always evolve like you could start like
here's the timeline cinematic and you
could like shift forward this is what we
experienced here then you can shift
forward and as that timeline gets longer
they could just make a piece that covers
whatever season just happens and keep
tacking it on and that way you could
kind of pan through and if you it would
be great for us as players who've even
played for a while to be like hey i want
to go back
see some of the cinematics that are even
in game just to be able to access them
and that could be an optional download
as you guys have said hey do you want
the old cinematics or something like
that to take up more space but then you
could at least watch them and then hey
you've watched them all do you want to
keep these on your hard drive for space
so you want to delete because you know
those files right sometimes take up some
space
and i was like exactly we have all these
ideas and we're like we'll just take one
of them
how cool would it be if that timeline if
you you clicked on it and then you just
went and watched your raid back and you
saw all the people you're wearing
like like split gate does right like
yeah the their their game saves of like
their clips are like five meg on your on
your hard drive pages it basically just
recompils it all in the game like that
would be so cool so you have all the
memories of like oh you had a raid
when he fell off and he kept falling off
that's what stuff would be yeah yeah
that was one of them
i know they didn't do it to the level
you just described but that to me was
one of the more
amazing things destiny 2's launch did
with showing you what you did in d1 who
was in your rave party when you
completed king's fall and all that stuff
and you know it was very emotional at
the end of the day you know there were a
couple of friends of mine that passed
away and i'm like wow you know what i
mean like you get to see it lived on but
i understand your point but that's
definitely a good point
well somehow we've talked about the dcv
for way too long
yeah always have different opinions
about it but i mean we start talking
about pvp versus pve
i swear clearly
clearly we have opinions about those
things no that's fine um what it is yeah
it's another one of those
forks on the road where you're like okay
take this stuff out of the game
that is one of those points where i do
feel kind of bad for the developers
though especially this season
because of the shattered realm it gets
to live for six months and bye
like and
we've talked about this like one of my
favorite activities the metroidvania
that travis like kind of stuck the name
and i can't stop saying that
and just the unlocks of everything
like take that and go through that and
even a legacy or something just as a
cool place you could still have the
three-week rotation but have something
to be like hey this cool thing in here
and all you'd have to do you wouldn't
have to have the compass unlocks just
when you do beacon one open every like
open all the little beacons that you can
interact with but you can still do it
those are some of the things that when
they make stuff like this and then it's
gone it's really it's got to be a weird
thing as a developer as well because
they spend a lot of time making these
resources yeah
and then it doesn't even last forever
that's always kind of see your creations
disappear
especially as someone who's a writer if
i lost all my articles like that be you
know mm-hmm be painful so no
it's uh why is traffic like where is
travis we got those archives i'm just
thinking about articles disappearing
i've had that happen before like
i think i think i had like five years of
my reviews just destroyed because a
server uh went went haywire yeah
i know that struggle yeah jesus so you
got you got a feel for the people
involved in that for sure yeah yeah for
sure but at the same time like if it's
overall especially if you work there
overall if it's better for the game then
you know
you might be all for it like yeah it's
like it does feel like whoever's in
charge now joe and and everyone like it
feels like they
understand the community more i think
yeah
i would definitely agree with that well
they're keeping that soon
they're not throwing it away it's going
into a vault apparently right so they
can take it out of the vault later and
they probably will we'll be doing
retrospectives till the day we die oh
forsake in here play it for the eighth
time
for the first time
destiny 4 vault of glass returns
oh yeah oh yeah yeah they we see galley
keep coming back
undyne
which one of you said it that could have
been yukok just was like
it's like galley is one of those things
and somebody's like we're keeping the
silver bullet on the wall please take it
out in case of emergencies and gal it's
like we got a delay
the engagement numbers are down
you got a six month season break the
gloves
exactly that's that's silver bullet baby
yep well before we get there uh next
week we are going to be getting a
potential new increase in difficulty for
the shattered realm so i don't know if
it's going to legend or master but we
are going to get higher difficulties in
the shattered realm i heard a rumor also
for astral alignment but i haven't
actually seen that mentioned anywhere so
i'm not sure if that's going to happen
that's just kind of one of those things
i've seen in speculation and you know
data and things like that
standard realm i can understand three
person you could run it so like and see
how they could do that one the sixth
person if they do like a higher
difficulty astral and then if it's like
not match made because it's a legend
difficulty thing and they don't do that
it's like it's gonna get convoluted so
i'll be curious to see if that's
actually true but
shattered realm at a higher difficulty
is that something you guys are going to
want to jump into is that exciting is
that just like i've done it all at this
point i don't need to do it again or
if there's secrets in the
whole secrets no
sure i'm always down for a challenge in
not you're a big shot at realm are there
challenges in pve travis or is it just
all rock paper scissors not right now
i mean i i i can't think of any okay
have you ever felt challenged by pve
content
in destiny
can you stream a solo grand master run
and let me know if you feel challenged
oh oh the call out
i want to see you solo a grand master
and let's let's watch this let's watch
this
unfortunately for that i would have to
be high enough i was gonna say are you
even high enough
the hardest part about pve is how much
they really want you to grind the same
activity i do agree with that and yeah
the timing is is the the no lifting is
the the difficulty of pve when you see i
think that's what people mean when they
say they're good at pve is that they
have a lot of free time to grind the uh
the power creep stuff
yeah they have so much time they go one
way through the map and then when
destiny reuses the content and flips it
around they go the other way back here
they're messing today
we're talking about like mario kart
mirror courses now
like go through a reverse direction it's
harder this way
teddy would appreciate it like a gm um a
master on your own is like saying do a
1v6 in iron banner or something right
last year 100 underlying yeah yeah
it's particularly intended to be played
like yeah like that's my point is with
pve anytime you you say like oh it's
difficult it's like oh yeah because
you're you like you have to make it
yeah
you have to make it hard that's the only
way
bungie didn't make it hard so that you
had to make it hard for that gm's they
decided you are this below level and
everything's gonna one-shot you go
pretty much pretty much
that's good which is not it's not pretty
easy with a three-person though with
three people they're not super hard the
hardest part is getting power level it's
it's not hard it's just frustrating
getting right
that's the differences like after
playing
too many souls games and other things
like even difficulty can be difficulty
done in different ways i still don't
love the way it's done in this game as a
pve person that's kind of frustrating
because i can learn skill and things
like that but like there are moments
where you're like hey i got damaged in
dark souls but i can heal myself because
i had a stupid moment where i got hit
but that was on me but every moment you
can recover you don't get the chance to
recover on some of these things because
right if you're not perfectly loaded out
you're not this thing or the otherwise
or you just sneeze and like your elbows
sticking out and you get sniped or
something like
there are points yeah it's just i don't
love the way that's done it's like i
still wish that felt a little different
but still it's we still you know bash
our heads through it
yeah there's no radar on you're used to
having a radar and they just decided
that week that they're turning it off
and then yeah i just got sniped no radar
yeah attrition is that the one where you
can't heal you have to stand on those
poles
it slows down again the last sector that
i did the little pools are sitting in a
light are because you kill a bunch of
goblins and they drop the little
lightning on the floor so all the little
restorative light pools are in the
lightning death
great so every time you gotta get one
you're like that that is game design
right there yeah yeah i i feel like
people who are good at pve what they're
really good at is having a ton of
patience for all the bs and like those
pvp
there is patience with yeah we're
trudging through rooms and i i go front
yeah that is definitely a lot of that
yeah for sure
so yeah higher difficulty coming and
then festival of the lost actually
begins next week as many of us expected
so we do get our halloween event they
did actually a really cool thing um they
worked with a
um basically an artist so bungie
collaborated so what'd you what were we
going to say no i want to this was
actually special for me because i know
go for it yeah go for it yeah luigi is a
good friend of mine he's actually
from the undead labs team from state of
decay he was formerly of the undead labs
team good guy we've had him on ilp
before right around when stated the k2
launched
and i kind of knew about this but i was
supposed to be quiet so i'm glad i could
talk about that but yeah so it's cool
he's a mexican descent very nice guy and
he's the one uh what specifically tell
me that he's a huge destiny fan huge
destiny fan guys like super passionate
and uh he was saying like yeah working
on something for your game i'm like
really you know i couldn't talk about
the time so yeah it was cool to see him
get this spotlight and uh get the love
from from the uh from bungie and in the
community so shout out to my boy louise
yep
yeah so he did a dia de los muertos day
the dead shell which actually looks
really really cool kind of like the art
style on it the direction that he took
and they showed kind of some concepts
that he did but they did a whole
interview with him and really cool to
see just like
bungie in the twab shout out an artist
work with somebody in the community to
like put something in game and tom you
literally said that and i've seen other
games do this too where it's like
you know if you go out and somebody
community sources it and steam does it
with you know the steam what is it
called
where people like make mods or skins or
other things yeah and i can't remember
the name of it i'll talk about them yeah
it's called but yeah and they sell them
you know they take a cut you take a cup
but some people like make decent money
if you put decent mods or skins or
certain things together by
putting their efforts in so it'd be
another way another way for bungie to
make some money but it'd be cool to get
the community involved because the
community for destiny has so many
amazing artists
prime example is this one so it's really
cool to see that kind of shout out in
the interview to go with it they could
just be like hey here's this guy they
did full interview with him so that was
awesome to actually see so that one will
be available for silver and brightness
when it comes to the mix you'll be able
to see that one come through and of
course we have dinosaur armor coming if
you guys remember that is yeah dinosaur
armor so who's uh who's excited for the
dinosaur that you get or did anybody
feel their class got screwed by the way
who got the triceratops
i'm happy
yeah we got t-rex there was like a
raptor do you who got tries triceratops
feels right for the warlock though it's
an herbivore it's kind of uh
haggard you know like we're gonna watch
your mouth
we ain't gonna do that
more like disrespect the t-rex is a
titan right i think so yeah isn't it
like they're like tiny arms always yeah
yeah that's fitting yeah the raptor for
the hunter you know agile work yeah they
kind of they got them right i was like a
warlock would be like the hunter and the
titan makes sense the warlocks kind of
that's probably a bit more of a stretch
but yeah it still is probably as close
as you can get well they get that cool
boots with the toe that's like the best
piece of armor is the toe on the hunter
i love a lot of the armor they've been
doing but
why have they still not got like the
year one stuff you remember the
ornaments they're still not there
yeah
apparently it's a technical limitation
which what are you looking for from like
say year one what are you what are you
wishing what's in here
okay the iron banner year one ornaments
are so good
with the fire
for some reason but that is in the game
but i think you have to apply it to
charles armor yeah i agree iron banner
armor was
insanely good
yeah from d1 we don't even
like people were saying with the dcv to
throw back for a second like whisper
catalyst outbreak catalyst there's
people don't have ways to still get
those and people are like well dead
man's tail and hawkmoon are about to go
away and be in the same boat we don't
have the old ones fixed so again i was
just like yeah don't hold your breath
probably not coming soon
yeah yeah so it's like those are some of
the weird things you're like how long is
it going to take for somebody who you
can now go buy the gun but you still
don't have a way for them to get the
catalyst
just they need to put them in there so
again
that's that foreigner that they're
bringing out that looks yeah
that looks nice i like that yeah
yeah that
i wonder how hard that's gonna be to get
do you think it's gonna be like a weekly
rotation where you can get like one
piece a week type thing maybe from a
boss or to like stretch it out every
verse for sure yeah it'd be time-gated
like bungie loves a good time guy oh for
sure for sure
yeah you'll you'll buy it with br with
uh with silver probably yeah yeah
we'll make that you get to get two
pieces of season
[Laughter]
get your synthords and weaves and
strings
yeah we lost our minds on that one oh
yeah oh yeah uh but we do have a patch
coming on tuesday that one's actually
gonna do
some fixes they're taking a champion out
of the corrupted strike just because
it's the ogre section between the two
realms
some people would miss him so he's
coming out crossplay ui is getting a
little fixed but the biggest thing
grand master nightfalls will now have a
100 chance to get an adept nightfall
drop
so now every time you run a grand master
you will get an adept weapon it was a
chance at before i don't know how low it
was but it is 100 now
i think this is probably what it should
have been the whole time if you're gonna
go barrel through a grand master you
should at least get something
i think i did like seven grandmasters in
a row on a double loot weekend and i
didn't get any adept weapons i got every
adept mod though i was playing with uh
dj oros and some other people they shut
up yeah he's in there i got it i got
nothing and i was just sitting there
like yeah this is really great guys i'm
glad we
were grinding through this strike we've
done a million times except for way
worse this time just to get nothing
there's one thing in the twab that they
didn't mention which is that it's it's
launching xbox game pass for pc next
week yes yes that's a big deal and i'm
gonna test it i'm going to test it i'm
super curious to see if it loads faster
because oh my god since bat light it
loads so slow now really
really yeah
i don't know it's really noticeable
there's no console you just you just hit
a button and it starts loading on steam
it's always been like that 10 seconds
waiting for it to open
now
it's longer i wonder if it's anything
with the now the mandatory anti-cheat
installation what if that has anything
to do with the could be it's definitely
slowed it down it's definitely slowed it
down interesting yeah i'm curious
because um you know one thing that i
have some relationships with the xbox
the platform team
and
i'm i'm always on them if they truly
want to spread the ecosystem correctly
the pc ports need to improve they really
do i've had some bad experiences
i think you guys mentioned earlier
it was one shout out to maddie with
definitely we talked about it you know
i'm always going to champion that
because at the end of the day you have
to take the pc community much more
seriously and from my understanding a
lot of this stuff is
you know uwp and when windows 11 comes
out hopefully they're going to dress but
i do want to see
how destiny 2
game pass
works as opposed to steve i'm very
curious about that i don't know so yeah
i'm going to be getting my little tech
on and maybe we could do some testing
and see how that goes as well i'm very
i'm very curious about that experience
yeah i'm super curious whether it's
different at all yeah big time big time
yeah yeah that uh 10 seconds you have to
wait to open up the game by the way tom
we call that the cheaters penalty
you all
but it's always been pretty bad
it's always been pretty bad though isn't
it
players pc players have always been
pretty bad
wow
long before long before destiny
i don't think he could i don't think
travis is going to work out long here
with you no no i'm just going to just
because
he was a temporary host
like literally the core tenets of who
you are this bear has been slandering
i love
just because i've got 10 macros assigned
to my mouse it doesn't mean i'm cheating
it's like have you seen those mmo mouse
with like 18 buttons on your left thumb
those things are almost crazy let's
crack me up
new right actually had an interesting
point though i wanted to point this out
um
he said free game pass for pc on the
same con that they use as a pay wall on
trials
yep yep they say that that is the thing
because you can get a dollar
trial you gotta find the game pass yeah
yeah so
it could be a problem
it's like yeah i was like i don't know
i mean i don't know if and i guess the
thing is i don't know if which queen is
coming to game pass anytime soon or if
they give this like
longer window and then it comes later in
the year or something kind of as they're
doing now i don't know what the plan is
but the fact that if they're trying to
get those a little more concurrent for
xbox and pc
if it's free on pc then that's
i don't know that'd be a thing i guess
though like if you do cheat and like
your main game pass account is linked
across all your xbox stuff and then that
email gets kind of screwed
that would probably get a little
frustrating to have to like log out use
a different game passer i know cheaters
are going to go around the whole thing
but i was like
if that's kind of linked at all you're
not going to want to obviously mess with
your main i don't know it's just
something that'll just open it up a
little the main way that cheaters
acquire accounts just from people just
selling their old accounts on ebay right
because because you also have to you
know level up and get to a certain point
before you can even enter trials
um i don't think many people are going
to be selling their microsoft accounts
on ebay
not
yeah sure i don't think you're gonna do
that so so it is definitely a concern
but
yeah
hopefully
it is interesting for sure
well before we kind of ramp tom if
you've still got some time as you're
here i was actually wanted to ask is
your kind of competitive um
trials we didn't get to kind of do the
retrospective on it last week
it got a little hot the week before
um sorry guys no it's all right uh it
was the destiny community got upset
[Laughter]
they hated the game speak for yourselves
they were so mad at me dude my dms you
guys have no idea people were calling me
elitist oh dude yeah like oh that was
just him i didn't know the dmv i just
saw comments on my video dude
so bad like i was gonna i was it was
like all week i was just like fielding
all these messages and i respond people
dm me i i like talk to him and stuff
that like why are you elitist why do you
want people not to go to the lighthouse
i'm like dude did you even hear what i
said on the show like i didn't say any
of this stuff like i don't know oh yeah
uh yeah the comments were interesting to
say the least but we've had the full
three weeks of experiment iron banner
was kind of the week off it is coming
back
um basically at this point they're gonna
leave it to where the sunday
daily reset is when they're gonna turn
on the flawless
um flawless pool so friday and saturday
are going to be kind of open matchmaking
sunday and monday are going to be
flawless pool will be activated it will
be normal trials there will be no
capture points um so that's kind of
where it's going to be going forward at
least for the time being they are going
to do the like freelance trial at some
point later on they haven't given a date
on that one but for the three weeks we
got finally again with the point and
everything else and where it's kind of
landed for the moment
where especially tom i want to start
with you where are you and all of this
trials experimentation that's been going
on and where do you think they've
settled for the moment
yeah i think they experimented with too
much too soon um to be honest um and i
think they've
they've they've settled at probably
where you they probably would have
settled that anyway because i think
turning it on
straight away was a mistake um so having
it this sunday feels a bit more balanced
but i'm still not sure about it like
i don't know i i played i think that
first weekend and then
i think we were just matching the same
people like i played at 6 00 p.m so
which is reset in the uk and i played
went flawless by about 7 30 or something
like that so pretty soon and not not
super soon but then like we were just
matching the same people straight away
because of the the flawless stuff so it
was not that was not a fun experience
but when
when it was open to everyone on that
first weekend like
it was great i i could i could then go
and you know grab clam and members that
i knew weren't you know the strongest
players i could take them through
like i think that's the biggest problem
with all their changes that they've
forgotten that people like like to play
with their friends and like like to and
i don't i don't always want to like have
a sweaty game when i play as well i i do
want it to be competitive but i think
the competitive level of trials should
be when i'm at seven wins and there's a
lot of loot on the line then that should
be match make me to the highest tier
players i don't mind that because i'm
trying to win
at that point i've gone flawless and i'm
trying to win additional rewards they're
pretty
highly valuable you're getting a depth
weapon and you're getting like golf
balls whatever they're called um yeah
yeah
yeah
so i think they i just think they
experimented a bit too much um
especially with the zones thing like
yeah how did you find this thing yeah
how did you feel about that
like it's fine i i don't particularly
mind that being in the game but like
there was some basic stuff that they
obviously hadn't tested properly like
you you could continue capping the zone
at the end of the thing together yeah
so like so like you would strategize
around that essentially to like protect
the zone and then just you kill someone
and the other two would sit on the point
and the person would come and run and
you'd all get 10 super just like
that's just silly um and then the way
that it just ran like like where they
put it
in the the spots were like either iron
banner or crucible um spots
i don't know like
i think it would have been funny if it
was in random spots
you know they just dropped it randomly
and a little bit closer obviously if you
were losing and stuff but
it's fine that they experimented with it
but i i don't feel like that makes it
particularly competitive having that
that zone okay like
so overall you you you'd be good if that
never came back
yeah i think so
like i'm not like a massive i don't hate
it yeah i don't love it and i think
they'd have to do a fair few changes to
it to make it feel a bit more balanced
like right now you're just kind of
ambivalent to the whole thing
yeah i think that's what most people
were because i think
a lot of people just pretty much ignored
it to the point where like you'd be like
oh though the guy's cap and it's like 90
percent yeah you're like lost that round
but hey we just got into our side now so
we lost the round
and now it's on our side yeah i would
say for me just the mo
the
like strategic movement of it hey we're
up four wins but let's lose one so that
now the points on our side and we can
just play defense and like turtle up and
it's just yeah
that i think is what you said it's like
for one the fact that it shows up
like straight away so you know exactly
where it's going to be
if it was like 30 seconds then it's like
hey it's gonna appear here in 10 seconds
or something it'd be like kind of a
and as you said if there was more than
just like a b and c
like you're telling me you have one map
to work on you can't like update a map
to say hey now it could have like 12
more different just put it all over the
map just to mess with people like
just to see some interest that would be
interesting but the fact that people
were strategic to be like 4-1 lose one
now it's on our side camp it got it done
that was the strategy
yeah and there was like basic
functionality with it which was just
broken was like wasn't it 30 seconds i
think but by the time you'd actually
spawned in it was like 24 or 25 seconds
you just that five seconds like it's
just just come on like
just basic real basic stuff there that
um that they hadn't got right but you
know it was a test it was a beta
essentially so it was fine but it's not
there this week so i think i'm super
curious to see how today goes because
yeah yeah this is like the combination
of the like kind of changes they've put
in there um and i think i i appreciate
where they were trying to go with some
of those changes
but they definitely like their
lighthouse experience now is a lot
easier than it ever has been for sure um
but i'm not a fan of skill based
matchmaking so
interesting what about a ranking system
yeah like a ranking system
yeah yeah yeah
the main the main reason i don't like
skill based match matchmaking in
destinies because it doesn't have
dedicated servers so if i get
skill-based match mate against someone i
could be playing
like someone in russia for me is really
laggy someone in china for me is really
laggy um
all the sort of countries are a little
bit further out than than the uk like
your connection to that person just
makes it really difficult to even
compete against them and they're good
players so it's like
that's not there's not a way for a
peer-to-peer game to to match make
people um yeah my main problem with
skill-based matchmaking is what they've
done in the past is that it hasn't been
transparent and you you have no idea by
what metric they're doing it and there's
a lot of theories that the way they were
doing it was based on play time which is
kind of insane to me because yeah like
playtime in pvp or just in the game in
general um but i think if they had like
a i just want there to be a ranked
system so that i'm playing against my
peers like
you know i'm not i'm not the world's
best uh trials player any anymore but i
not that i ever was but i'm definitely
not as good as i was and when i had way
more time to play destiny um but i i
want to at least be feel like i'm
playing in the same bracket as like
people who are at my skill level and i
think everyone should be forced to play
at their level in trials and and the the
kind of like wild westness of the
matchmaking system right now it just it
just does not lend itself to a very
competitive or even like well balanced
experience because sometimes you're just
getting destroyed and other times you're
destroying other people and it just
doesn't feel good
and they have lobby balancing now which
makes it even worse so it's like if
you're playing solo like crucible you
just want to play some chill quick play
you can nev if you've got like two three
thousand elo in a particular place you
cannot have a chilled session of quick
play because it will lobby balance you
to the point where you've got three
people who are basically
you know staring at walls um yeah you're
out there like i'm you know trying to
play the game here
and it's just it just doesn't work and i
get that people hate like people really
want skill-based matchmaking because
they're like i don't want to play these
higher tier players but but really like
that shouldn't be a thing you should
want to play them because it will make
you better at the game it makes you have
more game awareness playing people
occasionally i was like to a point i was
like i will say to a point yeah i was
like to a point when the disparity is so
big that you
because we had uh send nomad on a couple
weeks ago and that's kind of thing it's
like he likes games where you can
um
like i want to learn something out of a
game and if something is travis is
saying if i'm playing people around my
level
and there can be a decent range that
level there could be somebody like three
or four steps above but 20 steps above
there's yeah there's there's a level so
far that i don't get a chance to learn
but like as you said it's like
playing against better people than you
like even to like an incremental
percentage better it's like that is how
you learn that's why those brackets when
you slowly start to work your way up
that's good but if you're playing like
bronze the diamond you're like they're
doing things i don't even understand so
there's there's and as you said the
skill based
with you know there's some some wiggle
room in there it's interesting but yeah
it's like too far yeah exactly it's just
kind of weird
i think yeah i said
in the last episode that like he didn't
want he didn't see a world where bungie
would make trials like more competitive
and i'm like
i don't even want it to be more
competitive i just want it to be
like
bracketed i just i just want like you
can still go trials if you're super low
skill your kd your kda is like really
bad but as long as you're playing
against other people that are in that
level and that you comparatively are
doing really well at your level and then
i'll do well at my level and then the
gods will do well at the god level i
just want it to be a similar experience
across the board at all skill levels so
i'm not saying like oh you know make it
so only the best of the best can go
flawless i'm just saying make it across
the board a more competitive experience
where you feel like you're learning yeah
and i think that is definitely the best
way to handle it but at the same time
like just destiny as a competitive game
it's just it's never going to be
competitive regardless of what you do to
the ranks just really competitive right
yeah just because like the hitboxes are
huge appear like there's so much stuff
like
it just never will attract those players
that don't play it anymore um and then
they they have this struggle but they do
exist in the destiny universe and i
think it's not
every pvp competitive player in destiny
knows the pitfalls of of destiny and why
it will never be like a halo level like
you know arena shooter but the reason
they stick with it is because everything
else surrounding destiny is so good it
sort of is worth some of the
shortcomings like that's why i do it for
sure and i just think they could do some
easy tweaks to make their game a little
bit more balanced when it comes to
matchmaking and the way that they do pvp
i'm not saying like oh yeah this needs
to be like
an mlg tournament because that just is
never going to exist for the destiny
community but i just think there's
something there and they can do a lot
better of a job and then also i just
have a problem with people saying like
oh destiny isn't that therefore it never
can be it's like yeah yeah you know
destiny has never been defined by what
it is at the time like it can improve it
can get better and i just think when it
comes to pvp and the competitiveness of
it i just think they have a lot of room
to grow and yeah
it wouldn't require a ton of work to get
there it would just require them to
make some strategic decisions that make
it a little bit more uh balanced that's
all i think
i mean the other thing is that they have
such a a sandbox issue that they've
always had right and it comes again it
comes down to the revenue thing so they
introduce stuff like stasis and they
introduced that into pvp they know it's
broken they've tested it and they
don't just roll this stuff out and be
like oh it's oh it's broken you know
whoops
yeah because you get shot by that stasis
thing and you're like i'm going to go by
stasis that's literally why it exists
that's why op exotics exist like of
course
it's a marketing tool you'll know this
yeah let's go i don't know what it is
but like they do need to like fix up
that sandbox and like try and find
better ways around that i don't even
know if it's fixable man there's just
too many guns too many weapons and it's
growing we're gonna get
that
vapor i think
is an inevitability it is yeah it is
it's got to come back at some point
surely i i predict it will uh just don't
[Laughter]
the one thing i really don't want them
to do is sunset armor only because
the way that you stat roll armor in this
game is frustratingly irritating when
you get to like
you have 49s that and if you had one
point one more you'd have you know 50
stat armor yeah um
and stuff like that is is super
irritating so like i have the perfect
rolled stats on my arm where it's like
it's like 90 milly because a titan's
gate so yeah
and then i have like you know six
resilience 100 recovery 100 intellect
and like whatever it is on strength and
so you have your sets and good and
that's
yeah it's all perfect so yep i'm with
you on the armor because for me
as you said right now your stats are
good and i don't want to grind for
another set of stats so it's like if
they ever do anything to armor as we've
kind of seen before with like forsaken
breaking in stats
for me to care i just want to care about
armor again and right now i've kind of
said this multiple times i don't because
once you get your stats you don't need
any like i see a class item drop and i'm
like why
i literally have one of each style
master worked i never need to see a
class item for the next five months
and unless which queen does something
different
like there's no so that's actually the
only reason why i keep not the country
was just for the different element
and the elemental mods associated that's
all you need you need four sets of armor
right now that's it with that training
even that stuff they kind of yeah they
kind of walked back a lot of that and
like i remember you had to have like
void armor for like sniper and hand
cannon and stuff you don't need that
anymore
now now it's everything is elementally
tied to mods yeah that specific mods
only will fall now even with stasis now
the new stasis
armor like specific bonds are tied to it
that that's their way of making you try
to hold on that's literally the way to
extend the grind that's all
yeah yeah you know what they'll do with
armor they went sunset like i'm fairly
sure that because they know the way the
community react but what they will do is
they'll just bring in op mods
that are only tied to that particular
armor and then you're like okay that's
getting you armor that that's why i see
the stasis arm i'm like i see what y'all
doing okay they up they're making me
forced to go grind this this this
element of armor now some of those
things come back they'll call it you
know it's just going to the destiny
content involved
because some of that stasis armor you
can get like even in pvp you get an
extra orb on your super mm-hmm
and stuff
i don't think the pvp side of the
community have quite got the builds
stuff
like figured out compared to the pve
community but i think
in the coming months some of which queen
is gonna it's gonna be something
i agree
yeah
we will see if witch queen brings
anything else that we don't know about
which of course we've got more to come
but
glaives and legend difficulty campaigns
that's not against savathu not about
glaives
and all that stuff
yeah no doubt so we will see but to
allow our guests to kind of get off it
to the rest of this day and this weekend
we do want to let this man at least have
the rest of his day um we thank you sir
for joining us today i feel like this is
a good place to wrap up so
um is there anything else you wanted to
discuss at this point are we kinda are
you
good um
because no i know you don't get to like
you don't get to vent on destiny all the
time so we're kind of
we're we can be your outlet for that so
if you if you
feel like we've
i feel like we've gone through most
stuff like
the main thing i want bungie to do is
like i said it's
really to bring
like some of the creative create a
community into into the game and i feel
like that would be a good way to to
really uplift the community a bit and
then just to figure out their revenue
situation just so that is
it's just so we don't have to have like
because i think if people knew that the
game was ongoing and live they wouldn't
necessarily be worried about like if
they knew that after which queen they
wouldn't have to buy a dlc or whatever
yeah then that's this forsaken stuff you
know
wouldn't be so bad so
yeah but i think we've gone through
pretty much everything yeah yeah unless
we want to talk about sunset again
you know you don't want to be here an
hour anymore no no yeah we've had those
debates they were entertaining as well
not quite as not quite as
vocal as some of the other debates but
definitely a heated one that was
that was us
you were not friends for a little bit
yeah we we worked it out we worked
through it you know we got there
you know the child's debate you know
these destiny debates that everyone has
it's always funny watching the community
flare up about something something some
things they're obviously right about but
i think for the most part
like even the um the armor stuff like
that stuff blew up but like it doesn't
matter that much like i feel like you
you probably earn enough to be able to
do it anyway
unless you're like really into it so
it's like
i appreciate that bungie's like trying
to make their money and they have some
really sketchy ways they try and make it
sometimes it looks bad i appreciate the
sketchiness
i respect the hustle i respect the
hustle sometimes like
i don't want a game where i'm paying 20
bucks a month to play for sure
i'm okay with them and at the end of the
day like the
transmog is it's cosmetics it is what it
is yeah but the main thing that i was
mad about was three new currencies and
the whole class
i don't like that they
ended like there was a way to do it
without paying like they were like oh
yeah i know it's super easy all you have
to do is play like 80 hours and you'll
get yeah his armor i'm like if it just
says to us just take it out and sell it
to us if this is how you're going to be
you know yeah if there's anything they
could be it's just a bit more
transparent with the community for
sure those two years of like not really
knowing what was going on with auntie
cheat is
pvp in general yeah
yeah
it just highlights that they need to be
a bit more transparent in certain areas
yeah
i got two questions for you one what is
your favorite cookie or biscuit i guess
i could say for you guys right is that
right
cookie
i'm not really a cookie fan i like you
know oreos are great okay there you go
uh and then the other one uh i'm gonna
steal travis's thing if you could ask
bungie for one thing
going into which queen yeah what would
be your bungee please
hmm
take with a hoard out of pvp
okay
just make it so that i don't just like
you know like sneeze on it and i'm dead
i like that i don't know like
there's so many things i'd want but like
some that that that is a particularly
frustrating thing in pvp at the moment
yeah no that's
my question please that i that is
supposed to be it's supposed to be
something really like pedantic just like
a nitpick like that's a pretty specific
one yeah that's a pretty specific one
that's actually good yeah
i want 12 raids or something like no
he's like i want one gun out of pvp he
did what that was good i like that i got
my big pick right now my bungie please
that's just been on my mind forever has
been the tower versus the helm and like
yeah yeah
not being there and it's just like oh
that just
no i agree i hear you on that i did have
a question um being that you are a
raider
your favorite raid
um all the time nice wish to be honest
okay
why why why
it's gotta be between last wish and four
of class but like obviously four class
when it was
prior like it's great for glass now yeah
it was kind of special then
um because voter class yeah was
that well that was fun but last wish was
just talk to me i think that's the thing
about raids and like we were talking
about the difficulty and stuff yeah rage
really exposes whether you can follow
basic you know
things in the game and like follow your
team and strategize all that sort of
stuff um
and it's just
last wish was really particularly like
lots of different mechanics you really
had to learn
um and there's always that one guy who's
like you know when you know when you're
in like an lfg you know that you've done
every role so you can pretty much do
whatever and you're like oh yeah so
who's going to do plays or whatever and
then it it's like silence
the last wish is definitely that raid i
think the most where like it
exposes whether people have actually
learned that particular content or not
so whereas i think vlog not so much but
yes which the mechanics in light switch
like like i said earlier the pure fact
that no one actually does ribbon yeah
like you literally run into a wall
teleport and then just blast it with
whatever is the latest hot op where yeah
yeah
yeah
that just shows and that is the destiny
community in a nutshell isn't it like
anything that's cheesy
it's the community of efficiency yeah
yeah i'm the same i love the efficiency
and i love the jesus no i gotta shout
you out because i do like i like the
last wish choice it doesn't get enough
love i love the narrative connection you
know from the story into the raid was
beautifully done
riven encounter escaping with the heart
was was amazing
um
that's the first race actually good yeah
that's the that's an actual good
encounter i know everybody's uh skips it
but the first time i completely oh yeah
legit and it's a great encounter
and it was the first raid that changed
something in the in the game as well
right yeah
second yes the corrupted and um i always
got an affinity for the churro chi
encounter i don't know why the sure
introduces the chaos of all of it the
music is amazing and the speed just and
elevating and getting on the plates it's
it's all it's a frenetic kind of thing
so yeah salute to the last video
in there just run into the door kill him
die do it again
the greatest checkpoint in radius
the fact that you can literally go
straight to it without cheating is
awesome
so probable probably the best exotic uh
thousand voices okay 1k is up there bro
unique and cool and
using it in gambit was so toxic
when it first came out it was tied to
your frame rate the amount of damage
that you get
so if you had like 200 frames you would
literally map the whole team in gambit
it was the same i remember that they
didn't catch it for ages
yeah i i i carried that thing in gambit
and people i i probably that was
probably the period of my life where
i've gotten the most dm's on
like a xbox thing
every game people would message me and
just be like you are a
monster like you know
i'm so much worse there it is yeah i'm
i'm obviously taking out the expertise
but people were just like dude screw you
because i would just go in i would just
i was a constantly invading invader kill
the whole team
kill the whole team just constantly they
could not stay alive so upset hilarious
i love it
yeah yeah i've got
a lot of fun in this for the last which
just forsaken in general that's
absolutely absolutely i hope that they
bring out an expansion that's like
forsaken that level but i think yeah
they'll get that big it's just gonna
take them a while because they're gonna
have to home grow it build it up yeah
they go with the banger like a year 10
the unknown one right now is like the
ultimate
yeah man good stuff
well that i would say definitely wraps
everything up um got a little extra out
of you so we appreciate that one uh but
at this point i just want to thank you
for being here taking the time to join
us thank you for the reschedule twice my
fault and um yeah all the pc people
appreciate and now can poke fun at me
for a while
it's gonna be a lot of jokes but it's
totally fair i can deal i can laugh at
it now
because it's okay
um but at this point i wanted to kind of
let you have the floor to kind of let
everybody know if there's anything that
you're looking forward to anything that
you're doing articles on any coverage
basically to tell everybody where to
find or what you're doing what you like
doing all of those things uh the time is
yours
yeah i mean i am following the twitch
hack quite a lot at the moment that's
been the uh
this week has been insane because on
monday facebook was down tuesday windows
11 came out and then wednesday twitch
got hacked i'm like i'm like sitting
here doing its podcast
what's going on like something must have
happened right the podcast got hacked
don't worry
yeah yeah that was happening um but yeah
like i i i
primarily focus on microsoft and pc
gaming um and just pc stuff in general
so that's that's kind of what i've
always really focused on um so i'm on
twitter at tom warren um obviously
theverge.com all that sort of stuff
um i'm trying to think what we have
coming up
you got going what you got going i don't
know like i i feel like we just finished
like
like tech toba yeah yeah there's
obviously the google event next week and
a lot of stuff but like a lot of stuff
for me personally with the surface
devices and all the windows 11 stuff
just wrapped up so yeah you're pretty
busy couple of weeks there
yeah it's been it's pretty intense but i
think there's going to be
interesting expert stuff halo infinite
previews and reviews stuff's coming up
i played a bunch of that beta and like
it's really weird like getting used to
the the time to kill and stuff yeah
you played destiny right yeah you forget
um and and obviously not being able to
ads with half the weapons really because
you get popped out of it half the time
you need to though when you have no no
yeah yeah and you basically have like no
range drop off on half the weapons
either so
it's uh yeah a bit but a lot of fun that
was so i i i think leading up to that i
think i thought the campaign was going
to suck but now i think
i think it's going to be okay like if if
the game feels pretty good
yeah
coming out as well yeah yeah that's
going to be like
i get my 4k monitor at the end of this
month and i can actually experience all
the glory
yes he said forza horizon 5. yeah oh
yeah oh my god that's gonna be like your
technical show showcase oh yeah
playground playground is out here stunt
yeah man goats
yeah yeah so i'm looking forward to all
that like that's that's going to be the
next sort of
few weeks or a couple of months for me
really yeah it's like i know halo's big
i know four is this big but it's like
you know cod battlefield looking kind of
shaky i feel like almost might need a
delay depending on how that one's
playing right now it's unless it's just
an old build like i don't know if this
month is going to be enough for them but
it is weird to go into
like holiday vanguard don't really care
halo's big but it's in december but it's
like this october november i know
october has a lot of things coming but
the giant games actually aren't quite
there i feel like a lot of them have
been pushed a little bit but there's
still a lot to play like this week had
like far cry and other things then you
had kinah just a little while ago that i
just finished up and you've got you know
it's remastered yep i've got actually
i've gotta actually play that one
yeah i need to jump on that so it's like
there's a lot to do
but it's just not like playing you out
there right now yeah and i've been
buried in 90 hours of tree chopping so
you know
i refuse
i'm not building it at the moment i'm
avoiding it
it's going to blow my pc up as well so
i will say go into like your nvidia
settings cap your frame rate those types
of things yeah like i've done that
already like because the biggest thing
if you because i i don't have my 100
high frame rate monitor right now so i
wouldn't push it as hard it's only 60.
but yeah you can probably play at 60 and
be okay don't need to go too crazy but
um
yeah it's one of those things like i
haven't played world of warcraft in so
long so finally coming in and doing this
was like there is some kind of
satisfaction to what you're doing seeing
the numbers go up and that type of thing
and i haven't done even the big pvp
stuff and i don't know how long it'll
last it's 40 bucks one time no
subscription so again i don't know what
else is coming but
it's
it is fun for me in a weird way i just
can't explain it to other people like
should i is should i buy this do you
like it i'm like i do i have this weird
satisfaction out of it but i cannot tell
you if you're gonna like it because it
is not for everybody but it is fun yeah
but yeah like like you said battlefield
and call of duty
yeah like i'm not not that interested in
either this hillary picks a great year
to come out yeah yeah like yeah things
are aligning for halo it feels yep yeah
and it's free right so yeah free to play
multiplayer i hope he just doesn't get
hacked to death yeah yeah
for sure
because just can't wait to play the
campaign
yes
a living evolving campaign of 10 years
at least there's at least two campaigns
in this first uh but are you gonna are
you gonna wait for co-op or are you
gonna
like cause you can't you can't wait i'm
not waiting yeah i'm not waiting no i
mean i honestly i'm glad that co-op
isn't around at the beginning because i
prefer to have like my own meditative
solo journey and then once i'm done then
i'll bring in my friends are you trying
to force kill him right now what's
happening and interrupt you know what i
was doing so good avoiding an argument
with him today and then he does this
i was doing so good and then he does
this i love playing co-op campaigns but
i i never feel like i get the full story
experience with my friends chatting in
my ear and stuff like that and yeah of
course you could always choose to play
offline but then your friends hit you up
they're super annoying they're like yo
why are you playing solo campaign hop in
with us and i'm just like dude i just
want to be able to play the campaign by
myself once without anybody annoying me
and now that co-op isn't there at the
beginning i will have that opportunity
so personally i'm kind of happy but i
get why people are upset
yeah i i i like playing it with a friend
for sure thank you
on my own and like really you know
engrossed in the story and not miss a
beat but like yeah it is co-op's just a
halo thing man yeah i'm just a fan of
two i'm not saying i don't like
that but of course no but you did say
you like that it doesn't exist there at
the beginning
you did say that sir i'm gonna play it
solo and then when the co-op comes out
i'm gonna play it again with all my
friends and i'm gonna have a great time
and i'm not gonna be worried about the
story because i already did my solo
playthrough it's kind of perfect for me
i get it i get it though i get it
we'll see how it pans out we'll see how
it pans out
i just like that you know games drop you
know launch with the features they've
always launched with for the history of
the franchise i just like that it digs
to be consistent you know game
development is a lot different now oh
yeah yeah yeah
it's not yeah oh no for sure for sure
that's why i've always been a fan of uh
delay but i'm not gonna derail this
because
oh i've been on team delay
from from the beginning if if the
features are not ready and they've
already
delayed it for a year
could you imagine what it would have if
it would have launched with the series x
what we would have not sure what we
would have exactly at that point i don't
even understand what that means it just
shows to me but but there's a difference
between like the game being incomplete
or looking the way it did and all the
problems that they had and some features
not being there right away and then
being transparent about it that's
like if if the game is fully ready
except for co-op i'd rather have it now
and then that ad co-op later than than
to just delay it because of one feature
that they're gonna add two features two
features forge forge is the other
feature that before has almost never
launched with halo when it when is it
ever like a halo i think it launched
maybe with halo 3 but all the other ones
it got added
just shows to me that more time is
needed that's what it just shows to be
but for future shooters
they are they have existed throughout
the game throughout the history of the
franchise so it just shows to me it just
shows to me that more
development time is needed but they are
choosing to meet their halo anniversary
and the things associated with it and i
get it there's a there's somebody
financially going you have to release
this in 2021 i'm sorry i still feel like
that's true i think that they need more
time to develop it if you've played the
beta or the preview because that game
does not need more time it's that's the
type of player component
yeah but the thing that they showed last
year
okay it might it obviously looked rough
and and and the screenshots they
released i can't believe they released
those screenshots that was that was
pretty crazy yeah but like at the end of
the day none of that stuff really matter
i'm like a big graphics guy and all that
sort of stuff me too the way the game
plays right gameplay yeah that's great
in the campaign everything i saw was
like dude i want to play this game and
then afterwards i went online and i saw
everybody was mad about graphics and i
was like i didn't even notice to be
honest
with you yeah i'm with you there when i
saw the initial i just thought it looked
fun and it played fun and i thought the
grappling hook and all that stuff even
with after people dissected it and saw
craig face and saw you know the the pop
in at the top that didn't bother me at
all you know that's it i'm just i'm the
fan of i'd rather the dev take their
time and we know the history with staton
now um being in charge and lee going
it's clearly internal turmoil that it
took to get this game we can't say that
there hasn't been a struggle with the
development of this game and that's all
i'm concerned and to me i'm always on
the side of give the dev as much time as
they need and i'd rather have a great
product but again i'm not jinx in the
game i'm going to play it when it comes
out i'm going to be right there with you
you know i said i'm just always a fan of
hey give the dev as much time as
possible if needed
i think i think he's gonna blow up as a
multiplayer game for sure yeah
yeah it seems like it so far
and it's rumored like 20 maps or
something crazy like yeah really you
guys don't think it's going to be dead
in a month if it doesn't have a battle
royale mode
i say that yeah you know i wonder if
they took like the maps out of the pvp
maps that bungie like put in the content
vault and just
that'd be great although those maps
would not be good in halo also i don't
think destiny's maps are particularly
good but
that's true that's a whole that's a
whole other topic
maps forcing playstyles we can't get
into another podcast anyway that just
means we'll have to bring you back that
just yes
awesome
uh well that was about a 15-minute outro
for you uh travis what do you got coming
up
uh yeah i'm i'm doing stuff uh on igm as
usual i actually recently did a preview
for uh grounded uh they're doing a um
they just announced an update called the
hot and hazy update where they're
changing a bunch of stuff about that
game that doesn't sound like you're
talking about the grounded game anymore
but
hot days yeah
amazing
but they're they're adding a bunch of
like rpg uh mechanics to the game and
making it more like a obsidian game that
you would expect
and uh and adding some new areas so you
can see my preview for that on ign.com
uh follow me on twitter at ty got travis
i also do a um general video game talk
show called bitcast on sunday mornings
at 8 a.m pacific
right before the lords of the lords of
gaming do their thing after football i
think yeah yeah are you doing this
at the same time
i warned easily yeah we'll be moving out
of the slot back to our normal time soon
january what there's more than one
podcast
yeah yeah that's right that's right
actually we have found that some people
listen to both of our podcasts yes
simultaneously
are in the comment sections for both and
i'm like you guys are crazy there's no
way
what do you have one ear pod
i've seen my head on my earbud okay i'm
set all right and my brain exploded
but yeah you can find me there and uh
also you can find me here talking about
destiny every week how about you [ __ ]
no doubt first of all salute the
legendary tom warren
huge fan of your brother um yeah
following you journalist career for a
while
when he told me that you you know he
reached out and you said yes i was just
blown away like so cool yeah bro so cool
to have you here like i said love your
work love what you do in the uh windows
and the xbox community that the news
bits are great so salute to you then in
fact your destiny fan just automatically
makes you awesome automatically so
you're ready you're you're cemented as a
legend now but uh yeah at me at lord
cognito on twitter iron lords podcast
every sunday's the lord's day 11 a.m
eastern check that out and for those who
want a more xbox centric check me out
podcast check me out on defining duke
where mr maddie plays we've got uh two
episodes up one uh on the big team
battle we break it down well to find a
good ultimate we do we kind of go down
with that and then this week we kind of
talked about our earlier about the tgs
and everything going on with microsoft's
efforts in japan and the latest news
bits man and of course lords of
gaming.net a little smaller site not as
big as the verge but you know we we got
some people
you know check us out we uh talked about
the uh i believe the uh pitchford uh
restructuring and stuff like that but i
appreciate the support and of course
that last word podcast with these two
co-hosts of mine what i want to strangle
about halo but i'm going to refrain
myself
co-host i believe
his window gets smaller and smaller and
he just fades out of the trunk out of
the podcast
you're good man and of course e the
survivor the the pc survivor happy to
have you pray to let's go with you thank
the pc gods that i'm with you guys this
week seriously so i will i will never
understand and think however the miracle
of luck that things did not happen that
i expected because i was
expecting the worst and seriously i had
literally ordered a motherboard that
afternoon and ended up sending it back
so i mean
it was yeah it was pure luck but yeah i
will be uh
chopping trees messing around trials
i've got some my wife's family coming in
this weekend so i probably won't be
doing trials till
monday i'll be a little off on that type
of stuff but uh yeah for me you guys
know what i'll be doing i did get alan
wake so i mean i've got that one to try
and work through kind of a fun
experience i'm looking forward to if i
can peel myself away from new world
that's just one of those there's so much
to work up like
that's one of those weird games you're
like hey i want to make like an upgraded
bag so i can carry more stuff well okay
how i do i make the upgraded bag okay i
need this like one thing
well if you want to buy it on the
like if you want to buy it in the trade
area where you can do that one it's
already expensive okay so how do i go
find that myself well i've got to level
up this thing so i'm running around
picking up just hemp in this loop for
hours and i'm like not even close to as
high as i need to be so
no it is a game that you can lose your
whole life into if you choose so we'll
see if i can pull myself away but i
gotta get some destiny in this weekend
um and gotta get ready for the new
difficulties and stuff coming up but
yeah it's like honestly again thank you
tom it was a pleasure and you know
believe me it was um yeah kind of a
shock that you said yes but you've been
ultra nice about the whole thing and
especially after last week being a pc
guy i think you could empathize which
worked well
i i just i just felt bad because you you
obviously followed a verge guide to
installing your thing
so i just felt
that's awesome
my pre-gaming of all the heckling he was
you know the same he's saved the best he
saved the best one for the last right
just leave that one there
right there yeah i'm just that that one
that clip won't make it back out there
so um but thank you so much for joining
this episode has been a blast thank you
for letting us suggest the extended time
as well um and we'll definitely have to
have you back but for this episode to my
co-hosts
both of them
both lord cognito and ty guy travis
wouldn't be uh enjoying this thing as
much and probably hurting in the cheeks
after all the laughter this one and tom
thank you very much uh but for this
episode it has been a long one but it
has been a great one so number 168
october 8th for this episode it has been
the last word